SUBCOMMITTEE ONE WILL COME TO
ORDER. HI I HAVE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS REGARDING OUR
PROCESS. NUMBER IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS TO SENATORS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL MEMBERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
OF THE SENATORS ON THE SUB
COMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
. FOR OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASKED THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU RAISE YOUR HAND USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. ON MUTE. A SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN. STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT. THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW WHEN I CAN SEE IT ON THE
SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE THAT THAT
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE. OUR WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
TODAY WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA AND WE WILL DO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL THREE AT THE
CLOSE OF THE THIRD ONE. WHEN WE
GET TO THAT POINT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. OF THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WHITE ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LONG NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE ON MUTED AND YOU THE
NEW YORK THEN BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE POWER MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THIS HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTE.
IN TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING AND
HAVE AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM ON
ACCESS PROPERTY TAX AND COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION FUNDING-
WHAT ME ASK THE SENATOR MENDEZ
WITH ME NOW DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS. HE DOES NOT SO
LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE ONE THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM BUT TODAY WE HAVE WITH
THIS- TWO PEOPLE FROM THE GILROY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
PROVIDE US THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAM- SO OUR
WITNESSES ARE IN THE FIRST
PANEL. OUT FOR- MESA ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT AND CHIEF
BUSINESS OFFICIAL FROM THE GHYLL
ROYD UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AMANDA REEDY THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATOR FROM THE GILROY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WINNER
GRANT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MICHAEL R. FERRIS FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND MICHAEL FONG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. OUR ME JUST SAY TWO
QUICK THINGS BEFORE WE GO TO MR
MESA. ARE THE FIRST ONE IS THAT
I SPOKE TO THE GILROY CITY
COUNCIL LAST NIGHT REMOTELY IT
MENTIONED THAT THESE TWO PEOPLE
WOULD HERE BE HERE FROM THE GO
AWRY SCHOOL DISTRICT- TODAY THEY
WERE VERY PLEASED TO HEAR THAT.
AND SECOND POINT. ARM ALL THINGS
STAFF WERE CHILD CARE USED TO BE
IN THE PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE
ESSENTIALLY AND LAST YEAR WHEN
IT WAS MOVED MINISTRATION FULLY
IN THE ADMINISTRATION IT WAS
ALSO MOVED- COMMITTEE WISE FROM
SUBBAN TO SUB THREE HOWEVER WE
STILL HAVE. EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND AFTER SCHOOL
WESTILL HAVE PRE K. T. K. SO
THERE'S A PORTION OF THAT. BOB
BOB THAT WE STILL HAVE WITHIN
THE PURVIEW OF SOMEONE WITH THAT
WILL GO TO THE FIVE OF PANELISTS
I MENTIONED AND WE'LL DO IT IN
ORDER. WILL BEGIN WITH MISTER
MASSA THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE GILROY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT A
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE SIR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US HERE WITH ME.
ABOVE ALL OVER MINNESOTA
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT AND
CHIEF IS OFFICIAL FOR YOUR
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. HERE
WITH ME TODAY AS YOU MENTIONED
TERRORISM AND THE READING
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR. FOR OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS A BIT
ABOVE GILROY UNIFIED WE HAVE
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
STUDENTS. ABOUT 59% OF THOSE
STUDENTS FALL UNDER THE CATEGORY
OF FUNDING FOR LOW INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS OR FOSTER STUDENTS. OF
WE ARE ONE OF THOSE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR OF POOL
FUNDED CONSTRICTS. SO THAT MEANS
WORSE YOU ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN ACES. ABOUT
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND NOW
WE'RE REALLY THANKFUL AND
GRATEFUL. ABOUT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS YOU LOVE FUNDING. THAT
WE HAVE PUT TO USE TO EXPAND OUR
SERVICES TO OUR NEEDY COMMUNITY
HEARING GILROY- OUR DISTRICT IS
THE LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE CITY
OF GILROY- BUT WE'RE STRUGGLING-
TO STAFF OR PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
THE- SPRAY THE LAY. SHORTAGE IN
OUR ECONOMY. SO WHAT WE IS WE
LEVERAGE OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIP. TO DELIVER THE
SERVICE. ARE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
NO THE FAMILIES OF THE STUDENTS
KNOW THAT NEED. THAT WE HAVE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. AND I WANNA THANK
AMONG THE READING FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY AMANDA PLEASE TELL THEM
HOW WE LEVERAGE OUR COMMUNITY
BASED PARTNERSHIPS- TO THE
DELIVER THE NEEDED SERVICES BUT
WE HAVE- WE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
HEARING YOUR- THANK YOU ARE ALSO
. I AGREE WITH WHAT ALL OF US
AND I REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION PARTNERS THEY
ARE. VITAL IN IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS THEY KNOW AS ALSO SAID
THEY KNOW OUR STUDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT THEY KNOW THE
NEEDS OF OUR SCHOOLS AND- IT
ALSO HELPS TO BUILD THE PIPELINE
WITH. WITH TEACHERS STUDIES ARE
STAFF OFTEN THEY'RE- BILINGUAL
BICULTURAL. COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
ARE SUPPORTING. SO OFTEN IT'S
EVEN SIBLINGS OR NEIGHBORS FROM
FROM FROM WHERE THEY'VE GROWN
UP- I WANT TO REALLY THINK THIS
BODY FOR THE FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
ACES IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE HOW THAT
ALLOWED US TO REALLY GET
INNOVATIVE AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE AS I SAID
THE STAFF WERE REALLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT SUPPORTING THAT THE KIDS
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND THAT
FIRST
TO RELEASED. FIND NEW WAYS OF
SUPPORTING OUR COMMUNITY- AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS SUCH AS
THAT THIS YELLOW KEY FUNDING IS
BUILT ON SUCH A STRONG
FOUNDATION OF ACES IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. AND THAT'S-
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP THAT
GOING- AND I JUST WANT TO SHOUT
OUT TO MICHAEL FUNK DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN HE HAD HIS
FIRESIDE CHATS HE WOULD ALWAYS
AND IT WAS MADE WITH LOVE AND I
KNOW FOR MYSELF AND A LOT OF
THE- PARTNERS THAT I WORK WITH.
THAT WAS WHAT GUIDED US THROUGH
LEAD LEAD WITH LEFT WHAT WE
GONNA DO HOW IMAGES HOUSES TO
WORK WHAT HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. LEGAL STUFF AND THAT'S
AND THAT'S WHAT GUIDED US- WE RE
APPRECIATE CITY THE INCREASE AND
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR ACES
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THAT WAS
A- REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF. HOW
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TOKEEP OUR
DOORS OPEN NOW BECAUSE OF THAT
IT RATE INCREASES BUT IN THE
PAST. THE DO A SMALL INCREASE IN
FOR OUR STAFF. AND THAT ALLOWED
US TO KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN- FOR
RIGHT NOW DURING THIS SPECIALLY
DURING JANUARY. WHEN IT WAS SO
TOUGH- WE DO HAVE. AS I I'VE
WORKED WITH ARE OUT TO A
COMMITTEE ARE TO SAY WE WILL
NEED TO PAY A WAGE WANTING THE
PAY FOR A STAFF SO THEY CAN DO
THIS JOB JUST OF HOW LOVE IT BUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY ARE THEY
ARE ABLE TO DO IT- OF THE CAN
ARE PARTNER AGENCIES HAD WAS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO COLOR BILLS
AND THE FUNDING IS SEPARATE FROM
ACES IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THE
L. O. P. S. AS SEPARATE THEY'RE
NOT SURE. IT'S NOT AS NOT AS
KNOWN AS SMART- IS MORE
UNCERTAIN HOW ONGOING THAT WILL
BE AND SO THEY HAVE CONCERNS
WITH INCREASING THE PAY RATE FOR
STAFF- WHAT BASE BASED ON THAT
AND YOU KNOW CALL IT WOULD HELP
THEM TO FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE.
BUT ON THAT GOING- THIS ONGOING
COSTS. THEY ALSO MENTIONED THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE TO GO WITH THE
DISTRICTS FOR PEACE THEY HAVE TO
TAKE WHEN I SAID LET'S LET'S PAY
THEM THEY SAID HOLD ON HAVE TO
DO THEY HAVE TO DO AGENCIES SO
THIS HAVE TO GO WITH THE
DISTRICTS FIGURE OUT. AS OF.
SAID WE'RE DOING FUNDED WERE
VERY BLAH. HEARING SO WE ALREADY
HAVE. ENOUGH FOR. BAY TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR ELEMENTARY- SO
WE ALREADY OPENED TO BILL SCHOOL
PRO THAT WERE IN NEED OF IF
PROGRAM. LIKELY A SCHOOL THAT
WERE SUPPORT JUST SIX LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY. WAS BENEFICIAL AND
WE HAVE TWO NEW MIDDLE SCHOOLS
OPEN AND WE HOPE NEXT YEAR WITH
THE INCREASE IN FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO HIGH SCHOOL SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE L. O. P. M. I
DO BUT I DO TO HIGHLIGHT THE
MOST DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT WE
DO SO THEY WILL THEY WILL NEED.
A DEDICATED FUNDING FOR MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
PROVIDES KIDS THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ROUTE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND THROUGH MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
THEN WHEN THEY GET THE HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN THINGS REALLY START
TO GET TOUGH FOR THEM OFTENTIMES
WE END UP JUST SAYING OKAY WE'RE
OUT WE'RE DONE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE FUNDING FOR THAT SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT STUDENTS ALL
THE WAY THROUGH- THE- ONE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE. IS THAT THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS VITAL IN
OPERATING THESE PROGRAMS WE
BENEFITTED FOR YEARS AGO FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THE SUMMER
MATTERS CAMPAIGN. AND I HAD KEY
BRECKENRIDGE TEACHING ME HOW TO
RUN SUMMER PROGRAM AND
DESIGNING THE MODEL THAT WE THAT
WE HAVE THE PARTNERSHIPS AND-
THERE IS AN AMAZING SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
ALREADY IN PLACE. FOR ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE SKILL OPS
FIVE SEPARATE FROM MATH. AND
THEY ALREADY HAVE. THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING AND I JUST WANT TO
REALLY HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE A NEED. I FEEL FOR.
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
ESPECIALLY FOR NEW ELEAZER GONNA
BE BRINGING OUT A PROGRAM THAT
THEY DN'T HAVE THEY DON'T
ALREADY HAVE THOSE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH PARTNER
AGENCIES- THAT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY VITAL THAT THEY- GET THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THEY CAN
BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND
BUILD THE TRUST THAT WE'VE-
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS- WHEN WE- ONE OF THE
THINGS I REALLY APPRECIATE WAS
AT YELLOW P. WAS THE EQUITY
FOCUS. AND REALLY. FOCUSING ON
THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT
NEED THE PROGRAM THE MOST. SO I
WANT TO SHARE A QUICK SLIDE JUST
TO SHOW. THE IMPACT THAT IT HAS
WHEN WE YOU KNOW WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN INTENTIONAL ABOUT TARGETING
THE RIGHT STUDENTS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THERE A LOT AND YOU
KNOW THAT THEY CAN COME INTO THE
PROGRAM. BUT IN THE PAST YOU CAN
SEE HERE THERE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY THIS IS OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS. AND OUR FOOD IS LUNCH
RATES. PER COUNTY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THIS WAS BACK IN
SUMMER TWENTY NINETEEN. WE SAID
APPLICATIONS OUT TO THE TARGETED
STUDENTS TO WAS WE'VE ALWAYS
TARGETED THE SAME THE SAME
TARGET STUDENTS AND THIS WAS
WHAT WE GOT BACK SO IN ALL THE
STUDENTS WHO TURNED RETURN
OBLIGATIONS. THIS LAST SUMMER
SUMMER TWENTY ONE WE ACTUALLY
MADE PHONE CALLS TO FAMILIES WE
HAVEN'T STOPPED BILINGUAL STAFF
MAKING PERSONAL PHONE CALLS TO
FAMILIES LETTING THEM KNOW ABOUT
THE NEEDS ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND
WHAT IT CAN PROVIDE. AND YOU CAN
SEE HERE THE DRASTIC DIFFERENCE
IN THE NUMBER OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS THAT WE HAD IN WORLD
FOR THE PERCENT OF ENGLISH AND
WE HAD INVOLVED AND THE FREE
REDUCED LUNCH- SO THAT THOSE
TARGETED PHONE CALLS NOT
INTENTIONALLY REALLY HELPED. TO
SURE THAT WE ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF COMMUNITY WE ALSO WITH
THE O. P. PARTNERED WITH ONE OF
OUR AGE PARTNER TO DO LIST
SESSIONS SO WE CAN GET IN FROM
AND ON WHAT WHAT THEY NEED AND
HOW WE CAN SUPPORT THE BEST
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME AND
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WE
HAVE GREAT PROGRAMS WE NEED TO
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THOSE
FAMILIES THAT ARE IN THAT ARE
THAT WE'RE TARGETING- AND SO
THAT'S THE INNOVATION OF THIS
YELLOW P. FUNDING ALLOWS IT. IS
VITAL- THE OTHER THING THAT I DO
WANT TO. BRING UP IS OUR SUMMER
OUR SUMMER PROGRAM SO WE'VE
BEEN. WE'VE HAD A VERY STRONG
SUMMER PROGRAM FOR YEARS. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED LAST SUMMER WAS. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE.
COHESIVE SOLID PROGRAM. WHERE
THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THE L. O.
G. FUNDING WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE
TEACHERS CUSHION INTO
INTERVENTION AND THEY WERE
REALLY ABLE TO FOCUS ON SMALL
GROUP INTERVENTION THE TEACHERS
LOVED IT. ABSOLUTELY LOVED
TEACHING SUMMER BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO RUN THE WHOLE
CLASSROOM ARE STUFF FREE WILL TO
DO THAT AND ALL THEY HAD TO DO
WAS. TO THE INTERVENTION.
COMPONENTS AND THEY LOVED IT IT.
WAS REALLY POWERFUL IT MADE FOR
A CONSISTENT COHESIVE DAY FOR
THE STUDENTS- AND MY CONCERN
WITH THE NINE HOURS FOR SUMMER
IS THAT IT WILL FORCE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO'VE NEVER DONE THIS
BEFORE THE HOUSE LIKE THREE
HOURS IN THE MORNING OF A SCHOOL
AND SIX HOURS OF AFTER SCHOOL
AND THEN YOU HAVE A SEPARATE
PROGRAM AND THAT REALLY ISN'T
THE HIGHEST THE BEST. MODEL SO
FROM US I WOULD LOVE IT IF THERE
WAS FLEXIBILITY FOR LIKE A SEVEN
TO NINE HOURS A DAY OR INSTEAD
OF SPECIFIC HOURS MAYBE IT'S YOU
KNOW RANGE OF TWO HUNDRED HOURS-
OR SOMETHING FOR THE SUMMER SO
THAT SO THAT DISTRICTS SO MAYBE
AT LEAST FOR THE FIRST FEW YEARS
AS DISTRICTS ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BUILD THESE
RELATIONSHIPS AND BUILD THESE
CONNECTIONS SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE REALLY FOCUS ON THE QUALITY
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
I'M MOST GRATEFUL FOR THAT. THE
SYSTEMS I'M SUPER FIRST. LINE IS
THE CALL STANDARDS QUALITY. AND
COULD VERY CLEARLY SPELL OUT
THIS IS WHY A QUALITY. LOOK LIKE
THIS IS HOW YOU DO IT. THIS IS
YOU KNOW WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT
SO I REALLY. WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THAT I WILL CONSIDER MY
CONCERN IS HELPING TRYING TO
MAKE A NINE HOUR I UNDERSTAND
THAT FOR FAMILIES THEY NEED THAT
I UNDERSTAND THAT AN ASPEN
SCHOOL YEAR THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND FOR SUMMER AT LEAST WE'RE
GETTING UP AND RUNNING I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE.
SOME FLEXIBILITY THERE FOR THAT
DISTRICTS CAN REALLY- POCUS ON
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. AND
I HAVE A LOT MORE TO SAY BUT I'M
GOING TO STOP HIM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND I'M SURE
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
QUESTIONS WHEN WE GET THROUGH
ALL THE SPEAKERS. ARE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO WIN A GRANT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH GRANT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I'LL BE TALKING ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR THE YELLOW P. PROGRAM. THE
COST OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE L. O. PROGRAM
PROVIDING AN ONGOING TOTAL OF
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION. THIS
BUILDS UPON THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT INVESTMENT OF ONE
BILLION I'M GOING PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. AND THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
MILLION ONE TIME- IN ONE TIME
FUNDS WORKING TO. THE INTENDED
FIVE BILLION. DOLLAR INVESTMENT
BY 2526% TO STATUTE. ALL ELEAZAR
GUARD LISTS OF COMMUNITY
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
OFFER SUBSIDIZED YELLOW PT
PROGRAM SERVICES TO ALL
STUDENTS. USING A FEE SCHEDULE
THAT CONSIDERS FAMILY INCOME IN
THE ABILITY TO PAY. I GIVEN THIS
INCREASES TO THE PROGRAMS
ONGOING BUDGET BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
PROVIDING ELEAZAR- BETTER HAVE
ABOVE SEVENTY FIVE AT OR ABOVE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT-
UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE PERCENTAGE.
RATE OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT AND THAT'S
INCREASING THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO RATE OF ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PER ADA- FOR
LA'S BELOW THE 75% U. P. P. THE
RATE IS APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY SEVEN.
EIGHTY EIGHT THAT'S UP FROM. SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO PER ADA
. BUT AS A REMINDER CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES A HIGHER RETALIATES
ABOVE THE THRESHOLD 80% SO WE
CHANGED IT. FOR THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR FROM
80% 275% OF MOVING THE LINE.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF CUSHION FOR THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS PROVIDED IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. TO
ALLOW LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO CONTINUE BUILDING CAPACITY
FOR THEIR ELO PROGRAM OFFERINGS
. A LEASE WILL HAVE THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR TO EXPAND TO FUNDS RECEIVED
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. AND
THAT MIRRORS THE SIMILAR
TREATMENT THAT WAS GIVEN TO
FUNDS RECEIVED IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO WHICH THE
CURRENT YEAR. ALSO AUDIT
PENALTIES FOR NONCOMPLIANCE WILL
NOT BE ENFORCED UNTIL THE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. FISCAL YEAR.
ON THE AUDIT P. SPECIFICALLY IN
RESPONSE TO MANY OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ELLIE GAYS IN
THAT. THE TOTAL. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. AND
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE YELLOW
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
A PROPORTIONATE POTTED PENALTY
RELATIVE TO THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS NOT PROVIDED. I'M
ACCESS OR OFFERED PROVIDED OR
OFFERED ACCESS TO THE L. O.
PROGRAM SERVICES- AND THE NUMBER
OF DAYS OR HOURS FOUND OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. SIMILAR TO THE
EXISTING INSTRUCTIONAL DAY
PENALTIES USED FOR- OR ADA
INSTEAD OF THE COMPLETE LOSS OF
FUNDING THAT IS IN CURRENT LAW.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TRAILER BILL PROPOSES SEVERAL
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO FURTHER
FACILITATE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM. BY ELEAZAR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I THINK WE'RE HOLDING AT
THAT AND TELL THE END. WE ARE
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
MICHAEL FERRIS ARE FERRIS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WELCOME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MR
FOR. THE CREATURE ON THE MORNING
A TERM. OF WE DON'T HAVE- ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS. WE'RE
THRILLED THAT AND WILL PUBLISH
AND ALL IN THE COME WEEKS- AS WE
ARE REVIEWING WE DID ONE TO HAVE
A FEW KEY ASPECTS THE PROPOSED
THAT RAY FROM INITIAL. AND THAT
WE WILL BE CLOSED REVIEWING. I'M
THE FIRST IS THE UPEI OF
IMPLEMENTATION WE HAVE HEARD
FROM DISTRICTS THAT THEY HAVE
FACED CHALLENGES WE COULD WITH
EXPANDING THEIR ELO P. PROGRAMS
AND CURRENT YEAR DUE TO A
VARIETY OF REASONS. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY A STAFFING
SHORTAGES- ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DELAYS THE PROGRAM
APARTMENTS FOR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- GIVEN THESE ISSUES A
SLOWER PHASE IN A FUNDING. COULD
ALSO BE IMPLEMENTED. SECONDLY IS
THE- BLAME OF RATES AND PROGRAM
. AS PROPOSED THE PROGRAM WOULD
HAVE TO TEARS AND DISTRICTS WITH
SIMILAR INSTANCE FUNDING BUT
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
IN THE MONTH OF THE STUDENTS OF
THEIR- OWN CARDS THIRDS. OF FOR
EXAMPLE AN NBA WITH 70% OTHER
STUDENTS BEING. DUPLICATED
PUPILS LESS STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW
INCOME ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH. WILL RECEIVE A
LITTLE OVER TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER UNDUPLICATED PUPIL.
AND BE REQUIRED TO SERVE HALF OF
THOSE 70% OTHER STUDENTS- BUT
ADDITION WITH 80% UNDUPLICATED
PUPILS WOULD RECEIVE UP TO. TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE FUNDING AT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. FOR PEOPLE
WITHOUT. ALMOST IN REAL ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THE ARE ALL ENGLISH
LEARNER FAST YOU OR ON. LOW
INCOME STUDENT- TO A AND THEY
HAVE TO SERVICE ALL STUDENTS
WHOSE PARENT OR GUARDIAN-
REQUEST PLACED IN THE PROGRAM.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE- PROPOSED
FUNDING RATES MAY NOT BE ALIGNED
WITH HIS PROGRAM EXPECTATIONS.
ARE THREATS BUT WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION TRACKING. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS TO REPORT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ARE BY THE
PROGRAM. ALSO PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION DATA WILL HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER THE. PROGRAM
IS MEETING ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
AND ON THE LEFT SB WE WANT IS. A
ALIGNMENT WITH OTHER AFTER PRO.
EVEN AT THE ALREADY. FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL FOR IN THE FORM OF A ACE
IN FRONT CENTURY. OF LEARNING
COMMUNITIES. THERE IS A AND
EXPLORING CHANGES THAT WOULD BE
MADE SELECT ON YOU KNOW FOR
PROGRAM COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER.
AND WOULD BE A INTEGRATED INTO
ONE OVER ARCHING PROGRAM. THAT
INCLUDES OUR COMMON SEPARATES
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WITH
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND LASTLY ON OUR LIST OF
PANELISTS WILL GO TO MICHAEL
FUNK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. MORE
INSURANCE. THANK YOU ALL OF
CABALLERO ADAM FROM GILROY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR WORK THERE
MANY ELEAZAR THE STATE THAT ARE
DOING INNOVATIVE THINGS JUST
LIKE YOU. THE CITY IS GRATEFUL
THAT IM PRESENTING TODAY AND
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT. TONY
THURMOND. CD IS GRATEFUL FOR THE
PROPOSED THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE FOR THE
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
ACCELERATING THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR GOAL THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST BUDGET.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOTTED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL BASED
PUBLICLY FUNDED AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
THE NATIONAL LEADER AND
INNOVATOR FOR MENTIONING HOW
LEARNING COULD BE ENHANCED AND
EXPANDED. THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS DOES THE NAME CHANGE
FROM AFTER SCHOOL TO EXPANDED
LEARNING IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. WITH
THE ROBUST E. L. O. P. FUNDING
K. TWELVE EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY EDUCATORS WILL
COLLABORATE TOGETHER IN A WAY WE
ONLY DREAMED OF BEFORE. STUDENTS
THAT HAVE EXISTED. ON THE
MARGINS. WE'LL BE SEEING
SUPPORTED. KNOWN AND PREPARED.
IN A MANNER THAT'S WHEN WE SAY
LEAD WITH LOVE AND THAT'S BEEN
OUR MANTRA. THAT'S THE HARD WORK
IS ACTUALLY. WORKING TO KNOW
STUDENTS SEE THEM REPAIR THEM.
POWERFUL. THE ONLY A LEADERS
MUST RESIST. STARTING WITH THE
RULES AND COMPLIANCE. AND
INSTEAD LEAD WITH AN AUTHENTIC
EXPLORATION OF OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES NEED AND DESERVE. THAT
IS OUR PARTICULARLY WITH THIS.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANTAMENDMENTS
TO THE TRAILER BILL THAT WILL
FACILITATE JUST THAT. THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE AND I WANT TO
MENTION IS WHAT MADE ALREADY
MENTIONED IS THE PROPORTIONAL
WITHHOLDING. OF THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
APPORTIONMENT. FOR FAILURE TO
MEET ALL THE REQUIREMENTS.
BEFORE THIS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
. AMENDMENT ELEAZER STATING THAT
THE RISK OF IMPLEMENTING THE ELO
PROGRAM WAS TOO HIGH. IF THEY
FAILED AT SOME PART OF THIS THEY
COULD LOSE EVERY OF EVERY DOLLAR
OF THE APPORTIONMENT. AS WILL
NOW HAVE THE INCENTIVE TO DO
THEIR BEST. BE CREATIVE AND
INNOVATIVE AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT
FEAR OF BEING SEVERELY PENALIZED
. WE ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
TRAILER BILL AND WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE LEGISLATURE. TO
REFINE THE PROPOSAL IN WEEKS
AHEAD. AND THE CITY HAS BEEN
PROVIDING MANY VARIED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ELEAZAR TO
RECEIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
COACHING. AND THIS CORRECT OUR
SYSTEM IS GETTING STRETCHED THEM
. AS A RESULT OUR SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
FUNDED BY ACES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. IS REACHING OUT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY OF THE
EDUCATIONAL STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND COME
INTO THEIR MEETINGS BUILDING
THEIR CAPACITY SO THEY CAN HELP
SUPPORT AT LEAST THROUGH THIS
IT'S GOING TO TAKE THE ENTIRE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. AND- YES
MICHAEL MANY OF OUR ELEAZAR BEEN
STRUGGLING BUT THE MORE WE ARE.
MATCHING DISTRICTS LIKE GILROY
WITH DISTRICTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING OR SEEN THEM FIND A
WAY AND SEE THE POSSIBILITIES
AND START OFF DOWN THE PATH OF
IMPLEMENTATION. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TEST.
THANK YOU FOR OF YOUR TESTIMONY
AND IT'S RARE THAT SOMEBODY
TELLS US TO. PUT THE ROLE SECOND
INTENTIONALLY AND AUTHENTICITY
FIRST THAT WAS A FASCINATING
TESTIMONY. ARE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR QUESTIONS AND I AM
GOING TO START AND I WANT TO
WORK. TO DIRECTOR QUESTION
AMANDA REEDY GILROY AND FIRST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
COULD TELL THAT YOU COULD TAKE
UP OUR ENTIRE HEARING THIS
MORNING WITH YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE PROGRAM AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU LIMITED
YOURSELF THERE FOR SECOND- IF
FIRST YOU MADE A VERY
INTERESTING COMMENT AND HAND IN
THE CHART. THAT TO PARTICIPATION
IN THE PROGRAM CHANGED WHEN YOU
DID MUCH MORE PERSONAL OUTREACH
WE NEEDED PHONE CALLS INSTEAD
OF. ANOTHER METHOD I WAS GONNA
ASK IF YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP
DOING THAT IF THAT WAS A
RESOURCES ISSUE. UP BECAUSE IT
OBVIOUSLY LEAD TO SUCCESS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A YELLOW
DEFINING YES WE CONTINUE TO DO
IT AND I'M SORRY- COULD DO FOR
THE UNINITIATED THAT ARE
WATCHING AT LEAST ONCE COULD YOU
SAY WHAT THE ACRONYM ELO PIECED
AND- EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM THANK YOU-
SO YOU INTEND TO KEEP DOING
THAT. ABSOLUTELY AT ACTUAL BASED
ON WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THAT
EXPERIENCE WE ARE NOW. WELL AS I
MENTIONED HAPPENS MANY LISTENING
SESSIONS WE REALIZE OUR OTHER
STUFF THAT WAS MAKING THOSE
PHONE CALLS WOULD COME BACK TO
ME I UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT
AVAILABLE SO I WOULD. HEAR FROM
THE STAFF AND THEY WOULD TELL ME
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH FAMILIES
SUPPORT THEY NEEDED AND THAT'S
AGAIN WHERE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION PARTNERS. COME IN
IS YOU KNOW THERE WERE FAMILIES
WHO NEEDED FOOD AND CLOTHING AND
THE OUR COMMUNITY HAS A PROVIDES
A LOT OF RESOURCES BUT THERE WAS
ADDITIONAL NEEDS- RENT
ASSISTANCE. AND SO OUR CEOS WERE
ABLE. TO MAKE CONNECTIONS WITH.
WITH MORE RESOURCES THE
COMMUNITY AND FIND WAYS TO HELP
THE FAMILIES THAT THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARILY WITHIN THE DISTRICT-
EITHER NOT REALLY ARE. NOT WHAT
WE DO BUT OUR PARTNER AGENCIES
DO. AND SO THEY WERE ABLE TO
FIND RESOURCES FOR FAMILIES- SO
REALLY HAVING THAT
COLLABORATION. WAS VITAL IN
HEARING ABOUT. WHAT FAMILIES
WERE SHARING IT MADE ME REALIZE
YOU KNOW I HOW MOST MY EAR TO
THE GROUND I KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OUR COMMUNITY I HAVE A LOT
OF IDEAS ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO HEAR FROM
THESE FAMILIES BECAUSE
EVERYTHING'S CHANGED. SO DURING
THE PANDEMIC EVERYTHING HAS
CHANGED AS- AND WHEN WE REALLY
REALLY NEED THIS THE CONTINUED
FLEXIBILITY AND THIS INCREASES
FUNDING. BY EIGHT I DO FEEL LIKE
WOW IT'S FAST IT'S A LOT BUT
THAT IS WHY WE'RE ABLE TO GET
THE POSITIONS HIGHER THAT WE
NEED TO GET WERE ABLE TO GET IT
MAKES THESE BIG CHANGES THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN THOSE TAKE TIME.
AND SO IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
MONEY UP FRONT TO BE ABLE TO SAY
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THIS THIS
IS COMING LET'S BUILD THIS. I'M
NOT SURE IF WE WOULD BE MAKING
THE MOVES THAT WE'RE MAKING TO
BE ABLE TO CONNECT WITH FAMILIES
AND HEAR WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
AND BUILD THE SYSTEMS TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU AND YOU
WALKED INTO MY OTHER QUESTION
DURING YOUR COMMENTS. YOU
ACTUALLY LISTED A FEW. SYSTEMIC
IMPROVEMENTS- TO THE FOR. TO YOU
WOULD- OF FOR HELP. IS THERE ANY
THAT YOU DIDN'T LIST IN YOUR
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE
YOU CALLED OUT TO THE COMMITTEES
THAT WERE WHERE OF ANY. OF
IMPROVEMENTS THAT YOU THINK
COULD BE MADE FROM THE STATE
LEVEL TO HELP YOU FROM THE
PROGRAM. I AM SO GLAD YOU ASKED
BECAUSE AS SOON AS I STOPPED I
WENT. FOR ONE. SO YES THE-
CIVILITY FOR EASY TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ATTENDANCE- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY WE'VE
HAD AT THIS TIME. AND BECAUSE-
BECAUSE WE ARE SO SHORT STAFFED-
WE ARE NOT WE ARE STILL ON THAT
ARE CREEPING PANDEMIC LEVELS
WITH STAFFING AND SO THE
INCREASES THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO. WAS BASED ON THE ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY INCREASE
HAVE HELPED SOME. BUT WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF INCREASING PAY
RATES EVEN MORE SO THAT WE CAN
PAY A LIVABLE WAGE- SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE STAFF. EDUCATED TO DO
THEIR WORK AND- WE STILL NEED
MORE TIME WE'RE WE'RE SO NOT OUT
. MICHAEL AND NOW WE'VE ADDED TO
SITES TOP OF THAT. SO WE'RE MORE
MEETING NEEDS OF THE MOST NEEDY
OUR STAFF KNOW REGARDLESS IF
THEY HEAR FROM FAMILIES OF
FOSTER USE OR HOMELESS YOUTH OR
ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE FOR YOU
KNOW FAMILIES THAT REALLY ARE IN
NEED. ADAM GET A MAN MAKE IT
HAPPEN BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO DO THE MASS
ADDITIONS LIKE WE WANT TO. AND
SO WE WILL NEED FLEXIBILITY WITH
BASES IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
ATTENDANCE FOR THIS YEAR THERE'S
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THOSE TARGETS. BUT I AM
CONFIDENT THAT ONCE WE GET THE
SYSTEMS UP AND RUNNING AND WE
START INCREASING SOUTH PAY AND
WE MAKE ALL THESE CHANGES. WE
WILL HAVE THAT WE WILL BE BACK
TO WHERE WE WERE BEFORE WE WERE
MAKING. IN MEETING OUR TENANTS
TARGETS. AND SO ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY WOULD BE VERY VITAL
AND I AND I DO WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT. THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND DEALER
PEAK THEY- THEY REALLY GO. THE
REALLY GOING TOGETHER THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE WITH ACES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ARE. PHENOMENAL AND SO
IT INVESTMENT IS IT IS VERY WISE
IN MY MIND TO INVEST IN BUILDING
ON THAT FOUNDATION THAT'S
ALREADY THERE- THANK YOU FOR
THAT COMMENT. BECAUSE ONE OF
THE- EXCUSE ME ONE OF THE
REASONS. WE STRUCTURED THE
HEARING TODAY WAS REALLY TO LOOK
AT THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE
THREE PROGRAMS. AND SO. THAT IS
REALLY HELPFUL AND I HAVE A
NIECE. WHO WITH HER HUSBAND AND
YOUNG KID MOVED INTO GILROY IN A
MINUTE TYLER SHE- PICKED A GOOD
SCHOOL SYSTEM- AFTER TESTIMONY.
AND THEN LET ME ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
QUESTION. ARM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. IN HIS COMMENTS OF
THINGS TO LOOK OUT FOR WHICH I
GOT A KICK OUT OF BECAUSE HE
SAID THEY THEY HAVEN'T RELEASED
A REPORT YET THAT'S COMING AND
THEN THEY HAD A LONG LIST OF
THINGS THAT SOUNDED LIKE THEY
WERE REPORT. A SO THAT WAS GOOD
BUT- OF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
SAID THAT. THERE WOULD BE A
HIGHER. AMOUNT FOR STUDENT IF
THE- THRESHOLD. FOR THE EXPANDED
WARNING OPPORTUNITY PROGRAMS.
WAS 80% AND SEVENTY FIVE INSTEAD
OF SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. MORE IS
GONNA ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SORT OF HOW YOU LANDED
ON 75% AND IF. IN AND- LEADING
UP TO YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS. YES
LEENA GRANT PARK IN A FINANCE SO
WE DID MODEL VARIOUS PERCENTAGE
KIND OF THRESHOLDS AND IN THE
END WE REALLY WANTED TO BE AS
EQUITABLE AS POSSIBLE AND HOW WE
DISTRIBUTED THE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION I'M GOING TO PROVIDE A
LARGER SHARE OF FUNDS TO ELEAZAR
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
UNDUPLICATED PUPILS AND ALSO TO
FULFILL THAT ORIGINAL VISION OF
THE L. KILO PROGRAM. IN THE VIEW
OF THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH IS
THAT ALL AND LIAISE ABOVE THE
55% U. P. P. WOULD RECEIVE THE
HIGHER RATES ARE AND THAT YOU
JUST DID AN ACRONYM YOU PPL
SORRY THE- UCBCP IS UNDUPLICATED
PEOPLE PERCENTAGE YOU. YES AND-
AND THEN APPROACH THAT WE TOOK
IT REALLY MIRRORS THE ROUGHLY
SIXTY FORTY SPLIT BETWEEN KIND
OF THE HIGHER RATE AND THE LOWER
RATE FROM THE FIRST YEAR FUNDING
SO WE WANTED TO KEEP THE TRUE TO
THAT SAME KIND OF VISION AS WE
DID IN THE FIRST YEAR IN THE
SECOND YEAR BUT WE JUST HAD A
HIGHER. DOLLAR AMOUNT. TO WORK
WITH AND SO WE ENDED UP. WE
MODEL THE DIFFERENT. THIS FIVE
PER PROVIDED US YOU KNOW SIXTY
PERCENT- OF THE FOUR POINT FOUR
POCKET TO THOSE ELEAZAR ABOVE
75% UNDUPLICATED PEOPLE
PERCENTAGE. WELL I APPRECIATE
YOUR ANSWER ARE. THE CHOICES.
THAT YOU MADE BUT I WOULD JUST.
I DON'T DISAGREE. NECESSARILY
JUST. BROKE WE DO HAVE AN
INTEREST OF COURSE. IN THE BEST
OF ALL WORLDS WHICH IS THE
BROADEST PARTICIPATION AND THE
BEST AMOUNT OF SUPPORT TO THEM
ONCE THEY PARTICIPATE SO. ARM AS
MUCH AS YOU LANDED ON SOMETHING
I HOPE YOU WOULD JUST. TAKE A
LOOK AT IT OVER TIME MAYBE EVEN
THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS TO SEE THAT
IT CONTINUES TO WORK THAT. I'M
FIVE HARD TO THE QUEST AND SO
I'M GOING TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF- IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME. SANDRA BULLOCK
WITHOUT FEAR. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING YOUR TESTIMONY IS VERY
VERY HELPFUL AND VERY EXCITING I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I'M
ONE OF THEM HAS TO DO WITH- DO
YOU HAVE AND- HOW MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE
AN ASUS. OUR TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CLC PROGRAMS AND WHAT
KIND OF RESOURCES OR SUPPORT ARE
PROVIDED FOR THOSE DISTRICTS WHO
DO NOT HAVE THESE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE. JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT- HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
START WHEN. WE WHAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IF YOU DON'T HAVE ONE
SOMETHING ALREADY. ESTABLISHED.
IN THIS REVIEW TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OR THE- ALEJO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY OF THE
THREE OF YOU. MIGHT START TO SEE
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
AN ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION. I
DON'T OF THE CLEANING GRANT PARK
IN A FINANCE I DON'T HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS EXACTLY IN FRONT OF ME I
WOULD DEFER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THEY MIGHT HAVE THAT
DATA MORE READILY AVAILABLE.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DO YOU
HAVE THAT DATA MORE READILY
AVAILABLE. MICHAEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- WE ACTUALLY RESTARTED
TO DO SOMEONE ELSE'S THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS. AND CAME UP WITH
A FIGURE OF. OVER A THOUSAND
ELEAZAR THE DO NOT HAVE BASES
ARE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY BUT OF
COURSE THAT INCLUDES- INDIVIDUAL
CHARTERS AND- I THINK- WHAT
RIGHT NOW I HAVE STAFF WORKING
TO SPLIT IT UP BETWEEN PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PUBLICLY FUNDED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS VERSUS
INDIVIDUAL CHARTERS. IT'S A LOT-
MAYBE CLOSER TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
BUT I THINK WE HAVE INSTRUCTED
OUR SYSTEM OF SUPPORT FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING WHICH HAS
GEOGRAPHIC TEAMS IN IN EVERY
PART OF THE STATE THAT ARE PART
OF COUNTY OFFICES ABED AND CITY
STAFF- INVITING THOSE ELEAZAR
DON'T HAVE BASES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. INTO COACHING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OPPORTUNITIES- TO GIVE THEM
SUPPORT WERE ALSO ESTABLISHED
STARTING LAST FRIDAY WEEKLY
OFFICE HOURS. AT THE CD
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION EVERY FRIDAY FROM
TWELVE TO ONE THIRTY THAT ALLOWS
ANY L. A. IN THE STATE TO SIGN
UP AND COME IN AND GET DIRECT
COACHING. AND SOME OF THAT CULD
BE FROM ONE OF THEIR PEERS LIKE
GILROY OR FROM SOME OF OUR STAFF
- THIS WEEK I'M ACTUALLY MEETING
WITH. ALL THE SUPERINTENDENTS OF
THAT ARE PART OF THE ASSOCIATION
FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THURSDAY. AT
THEIR MEETING SO WE'RE WE'RE
GOING INTO EVERY OPPORTUNITY WE
CAN'T TO PROVIDE COACHING AND
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE THAT IS THE
CHALLENGE IS HOW TO REALLY.
PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE NOT
ESTABLISHED AN ACES FOR TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PROGRAM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MICHAEL I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT THAT IS BEING DONE TO
REACH OUT TO THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE THE PROGRAMS IN PLACE
BECAUSE- UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
PROBABLY SOME THAT ARE VERY
VERY- MATCHING NEED. ARMED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- OR
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF EDUCATION
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO DESCRIBE
THE ALIGNMENT BETWEEN THE THREE
PROGRAMS. LET'S SEE IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THAT FIRST. ELINA GRANT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
AGAIN I THINK- MICHAEL FONG FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AB
BETTER EQUIPPED TO ANSWER THAT
BUT I. IT JUST A- GENERAL KIND
OF VIEWPOINT THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT ASUS IN THE TWENTY FIRST-
THE ASUS PROGRAM THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AB. ELEMENTARY
MIDDLE SCHOOL PROGRAM IN THE ELO
PROPIA LOW P. UP PROGRAM- SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED AS SINGLE KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM AND- WE
SEE IT KIND OF. COORDINATING ALL
THESE FUNDING STREAMS TO MOVE
TOWARDS A SINGLE PROGRAM AND-
THAT EXPECTATION. IS THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE KIND OF
THE MOST STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE ADOPTED FOR PROGRAM
GUIDANCE BUT I LET MY AND- MY
CUT MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF. EDUCATION RESPOND
YES ARE ARE ASKED FOR MISTER
FAULKNER WAS GOING TO POINT OUT
THAT WE HAVE TO MICHAEL'S ON THE
PANEL SO. I SAW THE OTHER ONE
BLANK. YOU SAID MY SO LET'S GO
TO FOR YEAH NO NO FOR. THE ONE
ANSWER LAST. WEEK A MISTER. FOR
THIS IS THANK SENATOR FOR THE
THIS IS THE ONE THAT I'VE
SWIMMING IN- FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS BECAUSE- THERE
ARE SOME FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE EXPANDED LEARNING-OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. IT IS A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. ONE OF THE
FIRST IS THAT ACES IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY OF COURSE ARE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS. AND THE
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED. FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL SITE. ONLY TO
SERVE STUDENTS AT THAT SCHOOL
SITE. EXCEPT OF COURSE IN SUMMER
WITH THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL SUMMER
FUNDING ANY STUDENT IN ANY
SCHOOL CAN ATTEND THE PROGRAM IN
THAT DISTRICT. THE ELO PROGRAM.
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM FUNDING IS TO AN ALLEY A
AND THE CHOICE OF WHAT SCHOOLS
RECEIVE THE FUNDING IS THE LOCAL
CHOICE IN THE L. E. EIGHT. THE
ELLIE A CAN OF COURSE YOU CAN
CHOOSE. TO PARTNER WITH AN
OUTSIDE AGENCY AND RUN THE
PROGRAM OFF SITE. WERE SEEN SOME
DISTRICTS WHO ARE CHOOSING TO
PARTNER WITH THEIR LOCAL PARKS
AND RECREATION PROGRAM BECAUSE
IT THEIR FACILITIES AND THEIR
STAFF ARE LOTS OF CREATIVE.
APPROACHES TO THIS. ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON- MISCONCEPTIONS IS
THAT THE LEGISLATION FOR THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM STATES THAT ATTENDANCE
IS BASED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENT IN THE FAMILY THE
PROGRAM HAS TO BE OFFERED. AT
ACCESS HAS TO BE PROVIDED BUT
THE ATTENDANCE REQUIREMENTS ARE
BASED ON THE NEED TO THIS. IT
ACES IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THE
AT CODE SAYS IT IS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT STUDENTS
ATTEND DALY. HOWEVER THAT IS NOT
A REQUIREMENT THE ACTUAL
REQUIREMENT FOR ACES IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. IS THAT ELEAZAR
ESTABLISHED THEIR OWN ATTENDANCE
POLICY IN THEIR OWN EARLY
RELEASE POLICY. IT WOULDN'T
AUDITOR COMES THERE SIMPLY
CHECKING TO SEE IF THEY'RE
FOLLOWING THEIR OWN POLICY. THE
REASON THAT SIGNIFICANT IS
BECAUSE WHAT HAS COME UP. MOST
PROMINENTLY IS A CONCERN. FOR
ELEAZAR OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS- IT HAS WELL OVER THE
LAST YEAR AS THIS IS THE FIRST
YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION IS HOW
CAN THESE HOW CAN THIS BECOME
ONE COMPANY CAN HAVE ONE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM. BECAUSE
STUDENTS HAVE TO ATTEND EVERY
DAY FOR A SYSTEM TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY BUT NOT IN A LOW P. AND
SO WE'RE HELPING. DISTRICTS
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MENTAL
MODELS A WAY OF THINKING ABOUT
ACES THEY CAN DESIGN AND THE
TENANTS OF EARLY RELEASE POLICY
THAT GIVES THEM THE FLEXIBILITY
TO ALIGN THIS. AND WE STILL HAVE
DISTRICTS TALKING ABOUT TWELVE.
WHAT IF A STUDENT CHOOSES THE L.
O. PROGRAM INSTEAD OF THE ASUS
PROGRAM WOULD WORK WERE REALLY
ENCOURAGING DISTRICTS TO THINK
ABOUT THIS. AS DIFFERENT FUNDING
STREAMS TO SUPPORT A SINGLE
PROGRAM M. AMANDA YOU AND I'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS A LOT YOU'RE
DOING THAT IN GILROY- WHAT WE'VE
TRADITIONALLY DONE IN EDUCATION
. IS MADE SURE THE PROGRAMS WERE
SILENT IF IT'S A DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES THEN THE
CHILDREN CAN'T MIX BECAUSE
THERE'S DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
I'VE SEEN THIS IN THE TWENTY
YEARS AROUND THESE PROGRAMS IN
THE BAY AREA THE BAY AREA. YOU
HAVE A PROGRAM FUNDED FOR SCHOOL
AGE CARE ON THIS SIDE OF THE
CAMPUS A PROGRAM FOR ACES ON THE
SIDE OF THE CAMPUS AND MAY BE A
FEE BASED PROGRAM IN A DIFFERENT
ROOM AND THOSE CHILDREN WERE
ALLOWED TO MIX. AND SO WE'RE
ASKING PEOPLE TO UNRAVEL HOW
WE'VE TAUGHT THEM TO THINK. AND
NOW THINK ABOUT. THESE AS JUST
AS LEYVA SAID AS FUNDING
STREAMS. TO SUPPORT A
COMPREHENSIVE. PROGRAM IN
AMANDA'S GOT SOME GREAT EXAMPLES
OF HOW SHE'S. LEVERAGING THE ELO
WITH THE ACES FUNDING TOGETHER
TO BE ABLE TO PAY A LIVING WAGE
TO RECRUIT STAFF TO DO MORE
TREATED SIX I HOPE THAT GETS
CLOSE TO ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION. OKAY- FOR WORKING WITH SCHOOLS
THAT TURNED CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE ANY AND. WOULD IT BE
HELPFUL FOR THE PUBLIC IN
PARENTS TO KNOW WHAT SOME OF
THESE- FUNDING SOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE PROGRAMS ARE AVAILABLE
SO THAT THEY CAN START
ADVOCATING AND HELP HER LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS. I GUESS I WOULD LOSE A
QUESTION DIRECTED ONLY PROBABLY
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION MICHAEL FONG. SENATOR
WOULD YOU MIND RESTATING THE
QUESTION ONE MORE TIME NOT AT
ALL AND I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
IF YOU WOULD FIND IT HELPFUL IF-
THE PUBLIC WAS MADE AWARE
PARENTS WERE FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
MADE AWARE OF THESE. PROGRAMS
AND FUNDING AVAILABLE IN ORDER
TO ADVOCATE FOR THEIR STUDENTS
IN THEIR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FOR THOSE THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
F. THE PROPOSAL READY
ESTABLISHED. ABSOLUTELY OF
COURSE PAIRED OUT REACHES A CORE
VALUE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE HAVE STAFF
DEDICATED TO THAT IT ALSO.
PROGRAM STAFF ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT OR DEDICATED TO THAT
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY A FOCUS OF.
THE WORK OF THE EXPANDED
LEARNING DIVISION WE'VE BEEN
MEETING WITH SOME PARENT GROUPS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
EDUCATED ON THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE AND THE OPPORTUNITIES-
AMANDA MENTIONED LISTENING
SESSIONS WITH PARENTS. BUT
HERE'S THE TO ME THE BENEFIT OF
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS. HE
ARE SOME EARLY EIGHTIES. BECAUSE
OF THE STRESS OF. THE ONLY CRIME
VIRUS STAFFING TEACHER SHORTAGES
QUARANTINES HAVE HAD JUST THIS
THIS PROGRAM HAS FELT
OVERWHELMING TO THEM AND SOME
ELEAZAR SUGGESTING THAT THEY'RE
JUST NOT GOING TO TAKE THE
FUNDING THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM. WE WOULD
HOPE THE PARENTS WHO SAW THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR CHILD TO
RECEIVE. THIS KIND OF OUT OF
SCHOOL TIME EXTENDED EXTENDED
DAY EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM.
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP ENCOURAGE
THEIR ORDER DEDICATION AND THEIR
LEADERSHIP TO AT LEAST CONSIDER
WORKING WITH US BECAUSE WE CAN
HELP. YOU KNOW- MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOU MENTIONED. FIRST TIME YOU'VE
HEARD SOMEONE SAY DON'T START
WITH THE RULES BUT START WITH
THE NEEDS OF COURSE THE RULES
ARE IMPORTANT WHENEVER
SUGGESTING THAT PEOPLE FOLLOW
THE GUIDANCE NO NO I WOULD
EXPECTED YOU WOULD COVER
YOURSELF AT SOME POINT IN. DID
YOU KNOW DURING THE PANDEMIC OF
. THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE CAD DISTRICTS
TELLING US WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO TELL US WHAT TO DO DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TELL US WHAT TO DO
. AND I STATED ON THESE FIRESIDE
CHATS GO FIND OUT WHAT'S YOUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILY EEDS THAT
COME BACK TO US THEN WORLD WE
WILL WORK WITH YOU. TO HELP
FIGURE OUT HOW TO KEEP YOU IN
COMPLIANCE. AND MEET THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IT'S
THE SAME HERE. WHERE WE ARE
AVAILABLE IN OUR RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP COACH
DISTRICTS INTO COMPLIANCE ONCE
THEY DISCOVER. IN AND EXPLORE
WHAT THEIR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
NEED OFCOURSE FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
HAVE TO BE AWARE THAT THIS
EXISTS AND WHAT THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. PERFECT AND-
ONE LAST QUESTION AND ARE WE.
WHAT IS YOUR OPINION AS FAR AS-
ACCOUNTABILITY AB ON IT THE
SPENDING OF THIS MONEY MEANING
ARE WE LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTING TO SEE AS AN OUTCOME
OUT OF THESE PROGRAMS AS FAR AS
PERFORMANCE FOR THE STUDENTS
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR- I
COULD'VE MAKE YEAR I KNOW THAT
MUCH OF THIS FUNDING IS BEING
ALLOCATED BECAUSE OF KOBE DIDN'T
THE PANDEMIC AND EVERYTHING THAT
HAS HAPPENED WITH AB WITH
EDUCATION THE LIMITATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD. SO TO COMPENSATE
PEOPLE WERE ALLOCATING ALL OF
THIS FUNDING TOWARDS- THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PROGRAMS ARE WE
LOOKING ARE GATHERING ANY DATA
TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT THE HAVE
BEEN AT. I AND AS THEIR BEING IN
. ARE WE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
KEEP THIS- TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE PROS ARE ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE. WE HAVE ONGOING OF.
WE HAVE A REPORT TO LEGISLATURE
THAT IS IN THIS FINAL STAGE OF
EDITING ON THE ACES IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY PROGRAM. EXCUSE ME
WE HAVE. ONE THAT WAS SUBMITTED
TWO YEARS AGO. THERE'S A ROBUST
BODY OF EVIDENCE ON EXPANDED
LEARNING IN GENERAL AND THE
OUTCOMES ON STUDENT ATTENDANCE
INCREASE STUDENT ATTENDANCE AT
SCHOOL INCREASE STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT- WE ARE IN DISCUSSION
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LEGISLATURE WAS THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT. THE QUESTION YOU JUST
RAISED SO WHAT WE WILL BE
EXPLORING AND COMING BACK TO YOU
WE HAVE. A ROBUST BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS THAT HIGH
QUALITY EXPAND LEARNING PROGRAMS
DO YOU PRODUCE STUDENT OUTCOMES
ESPECIALLY FROM A WHOLE CHILD
PERSPECTIVES FROM SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL MENTAL WELLBEING
MENTAL HEALTH. THESE ARE SOME OF
THE BIGGER CONCERNS THAT
SOMETIMES THE ACADEMIC
INTERVENTIONS. I HAVEN'T
AFFECTED SOMETIMES IT'S MORE OF
A OF A NEUTRAL. THING BUT-
THERE'S NO DENYING THAT. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OUR STUDENTS ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW. WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES INCREASE
SUICIDAL. TENDENCIES FOR EVEN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CHILDREN THAT
CONNECTING STUDENTS WITH A SAFE
PLACE OCEAN WHEN PHYSICALLY AND
WITH CARRIED ALL RELATIONSHIPS
IS REALLY CRITICAL TO LEARNING
BECAUSE OF THE STUDENT DOESN'T
FEEL SAFE AND IN A PLACE THAT
THEY'RE CARED FOR LEARNING IS
NOT GONNA HAPPEN. SO BUT WE'RE
IN A PROCESS OF HAVING MORE
PRECISE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
COURSE OF TIME RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
PRIMARILY. WORKING TO GET
DISTRICTS IMPLEMENTING THIS
FIGURING OUT WAYS TO GET IT
DONE. AND OF COURSE THOSE OTHER
QUESTIONS WILL COME FORTH. AND
JUST OUT OF AS THE WELL YOU
REMEMBER I BELIEVE IN HERE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING HERE IN
THIS ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR ONE
YEAR BUT JUST GONNA CURIOUS IN
YOUR PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE OF
TWENTY YEARS. WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
WOULD BE A GOOD ESTIMATE OF TIME
PERIOD TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ONE
IMPLEMENTED AND NUMBER TWO ARE
BEING EFFECTIVE IN THIS PURPOSE. WELL EVERYONE WANTS A QUICK
RESULT LIKE WHAT HAPPENED AFTER
THE FIRST YEAR WE'VE INVESTED IN
A ONE POINT SEVEN FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. WHAT ARE THE RESULTS OF
THE FIRST YEAR. IN MY- IN MY
EXPERIENCE- LOOKING OF PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS IS AT LEAST A
PERIOD OF THREE OR THREE OR MORE
YEARS BEFORE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
SOME. SYSTEMC UNSETTLING THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE A RUN PROGRAMS BEFORE
. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
DEPRECIATE YOUR FEEDBACK THIS
MORNING THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER
MAN ANY QUESTIONS- THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THIS IS
ACTUALLY A VERY ENLIGHTENING-
TESTIMONY WHICH IS. USUALLY THE
CASE BUT I THINK THIS HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY GOOD I HAD A FEW
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON SOME OF
THE ALIGNMENT QUESTIONS THAT
WERE RAISED EARLIER BY MY
COLLEAGUES- AND I GUESS I JUST
WANT TO START BY GETTING A SENSE
OF HOW MANY SQUARE TO TAKE UP AS
FAR AS ASUS AND- THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY- COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS- WE HAVE IN OUR
NOTES. THAT ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA PART EDUCATION
APPROXIMATELY FORTY TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOLS PARTICIPATE IN THIS-
WHAT PERCENTAGES OF WHAT
PERCENTAGE IS THAT OF ALL
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE LIKE I JUST
DON'T HAVE A SENSE OF HOW MANY
UP. TO TWELVE SCHOOLS WE HAVE
SOME MAYBE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION YOU HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT. IT'S JUST OVER 40% SENATOR
OKAY FORTY PERCENT. AND I GUESS
AS A FOLLOW UP YOU KNOW I WAS
INTEREST IN THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
I THINK YOU ECHOED- AND MISS
MICHAEL- THAT. WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT. YOU OP ES IS NOT
ANOTHER PROGRAM BUT RATHER A-
ANOTHER SOURCE OF FUNDING. ARE
THERE. ARE THERE SCHOOLS OUT
THERE OF THOSE SAY SIX THOUSAND
PLUS THAT THE- DON'T HAVE
CURRENTLY HAVE ACES ARE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. CLC THAT. YOU
COULD IMAGINE HAVING E. LOP AS A
STANDALONE OR IS THE IDEA HERE
THAT YOU OP SHOULD JUST BE.
TACKED ON TO SCHOOLS. THAT
ALREADY HAVE CASES AND OR THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS. SENATOR THE
VISION OF THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM IS FOR.
FOR EVERY ALLEVIATE TO HAVE THIS
PROGRAM. AND ONE OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT IS PRESENTED
WITH WITH THAT WE HAVE A REALLY
ADDRESSED YET. IS THAT THE E. L.
O. P. I'M TRYING NOT TO USE THE
WORD ACRONYM B. LOP AS CHAIR.
BINANCE COSS KNOWS LEGISLATIVE
STAFF THE L. APPEAR THE SPENDING
UP THESE. ALSO REQUIRES THE
PROGRAM BEING OFFERED TO.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN STUDENTS YEAH WHICH
HAS BEEN A SLOW UPTAKE ON ACES
IN TWENTY FIRST CENTURY JUST
BECAUSE OF STAFFING RATIOS AND
STAFF QUALIFICATIONS. IT ALSO
ENCOURAGES- NOT JUST THE
BLENDING OF THE L. O. P. FUNDING
WAS. THIS IS A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY BUT ALSO WITH OTHER
SUPPORT FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
EDUCATION SO- THE DISTRICTS THAT
DON'T HAVE BASES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY COULD HAVE OTHER SOURCES
OF FUNDING. ARTIST PRINCES TO
SUPPORT HE K. THAT COULD BE.
BLENDED WITH THIS FUNDING TO
CREATE ONE COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM
SO TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE. WE
WANT DISTRICTS TO THINK
HOLISTICALLY WITH THIS FUNDING
AND NOT THINK ABOUT HOW TO JUST
ADD THE SONG AS AN APPENDAGE TO
WHAT WE DO BUT TO THINK OF THIS
NOW. AS NINE HOURS OF.
STRUCTURED SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THAT INCLUDES
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES AND THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENED DURING THE
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY. BUT THAT. A
DISTRICT YOU SHOULD THINK
HOLISTICALLY ABOUT NINE HOURS OF
CARE SUPPORT AND LEARNING
CREATING THE CONDITIONS FOR
LEARNING DURING THAT ENTIRE TIME
. AND THEN USING ANY FUNDING
SOURCE COMBINED WITH THE L. O.
P. TO ACHIEVE THAT VISION. AND
WHAT ARE SOME JUST FOR MY OWN
EDIFICATION- I'M I'M BEEN A YEAR
IN LIKE SENATOR AKOBO BUT- WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING AND HOW DO THEY STACK UP
COMPARED TO. ACES AND THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY SHE'LL SEE. WELL
CENTER YOU'VE JUST LEFT MY
YOU'VE JUST LEFT MY WHEEL HOUSE
MY COLLEAGUES I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF IT IS JUST LIKE.
ARE THESE THE TWO BIG POTS OF
MONEY OUT THERE ARE THERE OTHER
BIG POTS OF MONEY AS WELL WHEN
WE COME IN THERE'S FRIENDLY I
MEAN THERE'S- ELEAZAR ARE NOW
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE DEPARTMENT
THAT. ARE EXPERTS ON EARLY
EDUCATION. CAN OF WE CAN
CERTAINLY GET MORE INFORMATION
BACK TO YOU AND WILL- I CAN'T
RATTLES OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD
LIKE I CAN LEASES A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY BUT THOSE ARE THE
FUNDING TYPES OF FUNDING SOURCES
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE- FUNDING
SOURCES FOR EARLY EDUCATION-
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
KINDERGARTEN EXETER CAN BE WOVEN
TOGETHER. GOT IT SO UP ALSO IN
OUR NOTICES THAT THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR SCHOOLS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE HAVE DUAL
FUNDING FROM THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY C. CLC. PROGRAM AND
ACES- SO THAT'S THAT IS SEVERAL
HUNDRED SCHOOLS THAT WERE
TALKING ABOUT- MEANWHILE I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING AT FORTY TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS THAT I SAID
PARTICIPATE IN A SEASON THREE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE. I GUESS I
SEVEN HUNDRED THAT PARTICIPATE
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. OUR
PROGRAM. IT I GUESS MIGHT BE THE
JUST I QUESTION IS IF THE GOAL
HERE IS TO THINK OF YOU UP AS AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCE- WHY
NOT JUST PUT IN THE ACES. AND
DIRECTED TO THE PARTICULAR GOALS
OF EXPANDING LEARNING AND
LEARNING LOSS AS OPPOSED TO
CREATING A STANDALONE PROGRAM
WHICH YOU KNOW IF IT'S JUST A
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES. I CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT BUT I GUESS-
AND MAYBE THIS GOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT'S THE
IMPETUS FOR. MAKING A BRAND NEW
PROGRAM THAT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO HAVE ITS OWN
REQUIREMENTS LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO HAVE MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS- YOU KNOW
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO YOU
KNOW CREATE REDUNDANCY- EVEN IF
YOU GUYS ARE TELLING US IS IT
DOESN'T DO ANY OF THAT IS JUST
THAT. ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCE
- THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
CENTER AREA. BERMAN FINANCE
WARNINGS- I'LL TAKE A STAB AT
THAT. MANSER DOT QUESTIONS I
THINK THERE'S- A FEW REASONS ONE
IS THAT- BASIS PROGRAM SETTLERS
RIGHT WITH PROP THREE NINE THREE
YEARS AGO- THE SORCERER
MINISTRATION AND IT HAS A LOT OF
THOSE A LOT OF THE IMPLEMENTING.
YOU KNOW DESIGN OF THAT PROGRAM
YES CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AS A
RESULT OF IT BEING A BALLOT
INITIATIVE. AND SO THE ABILITY
ON THE PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OR EVENTHAT THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT ALTERNATELY.
TO A MAN SOME OF THOSE
PROVISIONS SOME OF THAT DESIGN-
IS VERY LIMITED BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE. I ANOTHER
THING IS ALSO INHERENT WITHIN
BACK PROVISION OR EXCUSE ME
WITHIN THAT- THE PROPOSITION.
MONTH THAT ESTABLISH A- ARE SO
REQUIRED AROUND IF ADDITION
FUNDING FROM. FOR A SAYS VAN
UNDER THE- THE PROVISIONS OF THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSITION THEN THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT AS WELL TO
INCREASE THE GUARANTEE. PURPOSES
NINETY MINIMUM GUARANTEED BY THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING MR REDDY
MISTRETTA **** JUST INTERRUPT
FOR SECOND I THINK. MAYBE THERE
WAS A DISCONNECT THERE BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S THE MINIMUM IN THE
THAT WAS CREATED BY THE BALLOT
MEASURE BUT I THINK SENATOR
MINUTES ASKING IF FROM GENERAL
FUND RATHER SOURCES YOU COULD
ADD TO IT YEAH WHAT I GUESS THE
QUESTION REALLY IS WE'RE TALKING
A SIGNIFICANT BUDGET OUTLAY HERE
FOR THE EVIL THAT EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM A
QUALITY LAW OFFICES FASTER BUT-
WE COULD DIRECT THAT MONEY AND I
DON'T. IT WHAT WITH WITH THEIR
BE CONSTITUTIONAL RESTRICTIONS
ON US AS A LEGISLATURE DIRECTING
THAT MONEY TO THE SAME PLACES
THAT ALREADY RECEIVE ASUS
FUNDING AND WITHOUT TAMPERING
WITH THIRD IT YOU KNOW-
INTERFERING WITH THE BALLOT
MEASURE AND I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS WOULDN'T THAT BE MORE
EFFICIENT POTENTIALLY. AND GET
RID OF SOME OF THE CONFUSION OR
DONE AND SEE. THAT YOU GET WHEN
YOU CREATE RENDON PROGRAM-
CERTAINLY THINK IT'S- POSSIBLE
THAT THERE COULD PERHAPS BE
SOMETHING. IMPLEMENTATION OF
COULD HAVE BEEN SOME
INTIMIDATION BENEFITS SO THAT
APPROACH I DON'T KNOW A PERSON I
DON'T KNOW THE ASUS PROGRAM
MYSELF PERSONALLY. WELL ENOUGH
TO REALLY SAY ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
A 100% FOR CERTAIN- I WOULD
MENTION AGAIN THE LIKE I WAS
GETTING TO WITH. MY POINT ABOUT
THE NINETY EIGHT THE BOSTON
NINETY GUARANTEE CALCULATION IS
THAT ANY FUNDING THAT WERE TO BE
PROVIDED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
ABOVE THAT- INITIAL AMOUNT DOES
REQUIRE- PURSUANT TO THAT
PROPOSITION AND INCREASE OR OR
RE BENCH. OF THE PROJECT NINETY
NANOMETER ANTIVIRAL I COME OUT
AND SO IT DOES EXPOSE THE STATE-
AND THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BUDGET
RIGHT THE NONPARTISAN NINETY
SEVEN. TO TWO- KIND OF A
DECREASE IN AVAILABLE GENERAL
FUND FOR THE NON NINETY SEVEN
BUDGET BY A LIKE AMOUNT SO NICE.
MISTER READY- LET ME TRY IT.
AGAIN AND IT MAY BE A DIFFERENT
WAY. IF WE WANTED TO ADD MONEY
IS THERE A WAY TO DO IT THAT
DOESN'T. CREATE ALL THOSE
PROBLEMS. I AM NOT AWARE OF THE
WAY. SENATOR CAN I TEACH ME
ASSURE CAN I TAKE A- STAB OF
COURSE YOU CAN. JONES SAWYER OF
COURSE YOU CAN THERE'S ALREADY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU AND
FINANCE ON. ON E. P. AN EAGLE UP
LET'S SEE IF IT EXPANDS HERE.
ACES THREE RED COAT IS A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM. THAT
HAS. MANY DIFFERENT- PRESCRIBED
ACTIVITIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AND FOR ELEAZAR TO APPLY FOR TO
ACCOUNT FOR. AS I DESCRIBED IT
SPECIFICALLY ALLOCATES A GRANT
TO A SPECIFIC SCHOOL SITES. THE
L. O. PROGRAM IS IN A SENSE THIS
MONEY GOES OUT AS AN
APPORTIONMENT. IT'S ACTUALLY
LESS BURDENSOME. TO ADMINISTER
M. FOR ELEAZAR ELLIE IS GOING TO
REALLY FOCUS ON. WHAT KIND OF
WORK PLAN ARE WE GOING TO PUT
TOGETHER WHAT KIND OF DESIGNER
WE CAN AND- CREATE AND HOW DO WE
IMPLEMENT THIS. PERSON'S GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS. OF WRITING
AN APPLICATION. SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT WAITED MONTHS FOR
PETITIONS SO I THINK. ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCES IS THAT
YELLOW PROGRAM FUNDING AS AN
APPORTIONMENT. GIVES DISTRICTS
MORE FLEXIBILITY THAN ACES IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY FUNDING
DOES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO THEIR DISTRICT. OKAY-
HELLO WORLD MULLING THAT OVER
YES SENATOR MEANT AS A FOLLOW UP
TO THAT- YOU KNOW I'M I'M OUR
JOB HERE IS OVERSIGHT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
PROGRAMS- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS I
ASSUME THERE ARE STRINGS
ATTACHED IN THERE SOME KIND OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
WHATNOT- ARE THE STREAMLINED
LIKE SO IF AS WE GO BACK TO THE
SORT OF THE ORIGINAL.
PROPOSITION HERE THAT
DISTRIBUTION IS DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES AND AS WE WOULD
IDEALLY LIKE TO SEE A SCHOOL DO.
ALL THREE OF ASUS TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY COMMUNITIES LESS
LEARNING CENTERS AND- EXPANDING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY. PROGRAMS
AND RECEIVE ALL THREE SOURCES OF
FUNDING. WOULD THAT CREATE.
ADDITIONAL REPORTING IN OR
OVERSIGHT AND OR- OTHER
ACCOUNTABILITY. MEASURES FOR
PARTICULAR SCHOOL OR ARE THEY
BASICALLY HARMONIZED SO THAT.
ARE THE ADDITION OF SET YOU OFF
FUNDING DOESN'T CREATE ANY
ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. THAT MAKES SENSE
AND I COULD BE FOR A OR- FINANCE
OR ANYONE ELSE. HELLO MISTER I
CAN TAKE A LOOK QUICKSTEP OF
THAT AND THEN MS- MAYBE MICHAEL
FROM DEPARTMENT AT ONCE- TO TAKE
A JUMP IN THERE AS WELL- HE'S
WELCOME TO. OXFORD TO MY
KNOWLEDGE- AT LEAST AS FAR AS
THE EXPAND LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM IS
CONCERNED- THERE IS NOT A LOT
OF- EXTENSIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AND NOT
LANGUAGE AT LEAST NOT TO DATE-
WHAT THERE IS IN THERE- AS WAS
MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE LENA
GRANT IN HER PRESENTATION. IS
THE PROPOSAL OF SOME ON IT
PENALTIES THERE WERE OTHER
PENALTIES IN THE INITIAL
PROVISIONS PROPOSED LAST YEAR
AND WE ARE PROPOSING TO HAVE
SOME REVISIONS TO THOSE- SO
THAT'S MORE PROPORTIONATE
PENALTY NOT YOU KNOW WHAT OKAY.
ALL OR NOTHING PENALTY- BUT
THAT'S NOT SO MUCH A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IT'S KIND OF JUST
BACK IN ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE
ANNUAL AUDIT LIKE WE HAVE FOR A
LOT OF PROGRAMS RIGHT- SO I
COULDN'T AND I UNFORTUNATELY GOT
I DON'T HAVE AS MUCHEXPERTISE
WHEN IT COMES TO ASUS OR SOME OF
THESE OTHER. SIMILAR PROGRAMS SO
MADE APARTMENT THAT COULD SPEAK
IN ON THAT REGARD IN TERMS OF
REPORTING BURDENS ON AN ALLEY
ANY- BUT CERTAINLY LIKE MICHAEL
IT TO EARLIER WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS IN IN THE-
SEVERAL MONTHS FROM THE
ENACTMENT IN JUNE. SALAS THE
PROGRAM ABOUT WAYS THAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE THINGS
STILL CHEAT THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM- BUT PERHAPS STREAMLINE
THINGS FOR AT LEAST THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE AND CERTAINLY THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE STILL ONGOING
AND I THINK THAT. WOULD
DEFINITELY BE YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS. NOT A THANK YOU
CENTER. ONE MARK- SO I THINK YOU
SAW OF STARTED ANSWERING THIS IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OTHER. BUT I
JUST WANTED TO LIKE GET A CLEAR
ANSWER. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT-
EXPANDED THE EVA PROGRAM. THE
WAY I THINK ABOUT IT AFTER
HEARING SOME OF YOUR ANSWERS IS
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE. SOME
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO.
IMPLEMENTING THIS. IN SCHOOLS
THAT ALREADY HAVE ACES AND OR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- AND THEN
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT CHALLENGES IN
IMPLEMENTING AND SCHOOL THAT.
DOES NOT HAVE. ANY AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING. WHAT DO YOU SEE IN
BOTH CASES A SCHOOL THAT HAS
ACES OR TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IN
A SCHOOL THAT DOES NOT HAVE ANY
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMMING. WHAT
HE SEES THE CHALLENGES IN
SCALING UP BECAUSE I THINK WE
HEARD FROM ALEJO. THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
I'VE HEARD THIS FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN MY- DISTRICT I
REPRESENT. THAT THERE ARE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE AND IT IN
IMPLEMENTING THIS PARTICULARLY
AT THE PACE THAT'S ANTICIPATED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. SO WHAT
DO YOU SEE AS THE ACTUAL
CHALLENGES IS THAT FACILITIES IS
IT. STAFFING IS IT- PROGRAMMING
SOMETHING ELSE AND. AND I THINK
WE COULD START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION HERE. THE
PROBLEM WITH CHALLENGE. IN
EITHER CASE IN EITHER SCENARIO.
IS WORKFORCE. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE. SOME WHO ARE TRYING TO
THINK THROUGH THE CHALLENGES IN
FACILITIES WITH OFFERING THE
PROGRAM TO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. AND I THINK SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES ALSO FACING
DISTRICTS IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE T. K. PROGRAM- WITH FOR
EVERY DISTRICT ARE FOR TALK
ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
I CAN OFFER A DISTRICT THAT HAS
DEVELOPED INNOVATIVE AND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS- AND HAS
OVERCOME THOSE CHALLENGES SO. I
THINK THE WORK IS TO CREATE. A
PEER NETWORKS WITH DISTRICTS TO
CONNECT DISTRICTS WHO ARE. MAYBE
HAVING DIFFICULTY THINKING
THROUGH THE CHALLENGES WITH THE
DISTRICT WHO HAS FOUND A WAY TO
. SEE THE CHALLENGE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY. AND I THINK FOR
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
PRIMARILY THINKING THIS IS WHAT
OUR DISTRICT HAS TO IMPLEMENT
WITH OUR OWN STAFF WE HAVE TO
HIRE NEW STAFF OR IN OUR OWN
FACILITIES. CONNECTING THEM WITH
DISTRICTS WHO HAVE REALLY TAKEN
A CLOSE LOOK. WHAT OTHER ASSETS
ARE OUT THERE IN IN AND AROUND
OUR COMMUNITY EVEN IN SMALL
RURAL DISTRICTS TO FIND A WAY TO
BUILD NEW PARTNERSHIPS NOW WE'RE
STARTING TO GET TO THIS NOTION
OF COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WHICH IS
ALSO. IN THE BUDGET AND ANOTHER
INITIATIVE. BUT FOR A SMALL
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS DONE WELL ARE
A WAY OF. THINKING OF PARTNERING
AND CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS. THAT THINKS ABOUT.
MAYBE SOME TYPES OF PARTNERSHIPS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE AND
ALWAYS CONSIDERED IN THE PAST.
AND SO I THINK. THE QUICKEST AND
BEST SOLUTION IS TO. YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE THING FOR ME TO SAY IN
A MEETING OR WEBINAR CONSIDER
THIS OR DO THAT BUT IF THE
DISTRICT WHO'S HAVING DIFFICULTY
IT'S A CHANCE TO TALK TO AMANDA
AND HER PEERS A GILROY AND TALK
THROUGH THE PEER TO PEER
INTERACTION IS REALLY WORKING
I'VE SEEN IT WORK. A LOT AS
WE'VE PROVIDED OPPORTUNITIES TO
CREATE NETWORKING AND GET THESE
DISTRICTS TO WORK OGETHER AND
KNOW THAT THE ANSWERS THAT THEY
NEED. ARE OFTEN. IN IN THE
COMMUNITY NEXT DOOR. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE ANSWERS
AND- I JUST WANT TO SAY THE
CONCLUDED OF THIS A SEGMENT THAT
I DO BELIEVE A PLOT THAT THE
GOALS HERE OF ADDRESSING-
LEARNING LAWSON OF THIS PROGRAM
BUT- OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPORTANT
MAKE SURE WE GET THIS RIGHT SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL RESPONSES. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MEN. AND
WE HAVE NO MORE QUESTIONS IS
THAT CORRECT YEAH. OKAY THEN-
LET ME THANK EVERYONE WE DON'T
USUALLY HAVE A CHANCE. FOR SUCH
A THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION BUT
THAT'S WHAT THIS WAS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED AND I THINK
THAT- JUST TO REPEAT WHAT I'VE
SAID IN THE TWO PREVIOUS
HEARINGS- THE JANTAN BUDGET
DOESN'T ALWAYS RESEMBLE CLOSELY
THE BUDGET THAT IS ADOPTED. AT
THE END OF THE YEAR AND THE
REASON IT DOESN'T S. DISCUSSIONS
LIKE WE JUST TAPPED. BECAUSE
OUR- FINANCE AND TO SOME EXTENT
THE OHIO DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
NO LET JUST LET YOUR CALL TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. OF THE COMMENTS
WHEN WE DRILL DEEPLY INTO THIS
AND SEE IF THERE'S SOME PLACES
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE IT GOING
FORWARD THIS CONVERSATION WAS
REALLY HELPFUL TO THAT. I
PARTICULARLY WANT TO THANK THE
PEOPLE FROM GILROY FOR
PARTICIPATING. ALWAYS REALLY
HELPFUL TO HEAR WHAT IT'S LIKE
ON THE GROUND SO. PROJECT THAT
DISCUSSION WE WILL MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO. WHICH IS A
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
PROPOSALS. AND I'M SORRY DIDN'T
GO OVER THE NAMES BEFOREHAND AND
I HOPE I DON'T SLAUGHTER
SOMEBODY'S NAME HERE BUT WE HAVE
WAS M<c.red> FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF</c>
FINANCE AMY LEE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND HEATHER CALUMNIES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF.
EDUCATION AND WILL BEGIN. WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING I'M APOLOGIES HAVE OUT A
LAST MINUTE CHANGE LIVES MAIS
INTERNET JUST PROP SO I WILL BE-
COVERING AND SHE WILL JOIN US IF
SHE'S ABLE TO GET CONNECTED TO
THE HEARING. AMBER ALEXANDER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AS MANY OF THE IN THE FIELD HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE GENERAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS FIRST.
SOLIDIFICATION INVESTMENTS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET CONTINUE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SYSTEMS ARE
INTEGRATED IN THE ALLEYS ARE
APPROACHING PLANNING FOR THEIR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
GREATER ALIGNMENT WITH PLANNING
FOR ALL STUDENTS. THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSALS WERE DEVELOPED WITH
BOTH IN ATTENTION TO THE
CHALLENGES BUT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES ARE FACING AS THEY
CONTINUE TO NAVIGATE KOPET. AS
WELL AS THE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM SERVING
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN RESOURCES AND SUPPORTED
PROGRAMMATIC IMPROVEMENTS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTINUES TO
BUILD UPON THESE INVESTMENTS BY
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASED FUNDING.
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
INCLUDED FOR GROWTH IN COLOR. IN
ADDITION TO THE AUGMENTED BSED
FUNDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TO CALCULATE SPECIAL
EDUCATION BASED FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS AT THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY LEVEL RATHER
THAN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL
PLAN AREA OR SILVA LEVEL. THIS
IS INTENDED TO PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY AND IMPROVE EACH
ELEAZAR ABILITY TO PROTECT THEIR
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS AND SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS AND COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM ANY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BETTER TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT THE INDIVIDUAL ADA
FLUCTUATIONS THAT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES- ARE
EXPERIENCING AS THEY CALCULATE
THE BASE SPENDING. IN ADDITION
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO CONSOLIDATE TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXTRAORDINARY
HOSPITALS INTO A SINGLE POSSIBLE
TO SIMPLIFY THE CURRENT AND
FUNDING FORMULA. AGAIN THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE A TECHNICAL TEAM-
WITH NO PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES
BEING PROPOSED ALONG WITH
CONSOLIDATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
ALLOCATE EDUCATIONALLY RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES RATHER THAN TO
SOUTHWEST. AND AS A REMINDER-
SAID THIS EDUCATIONALLY RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING
WAS CLASSED AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY AND BUDGET ACT AND
NOW IT IS USED TO BENEFIT ALL
STUDENTS. IT STEPPING UP THIS
FUNDS WOULD NOT PROHIBIT THE
POOLING OF RESOURCES INTO REACH
ALSO SERVICES IN SMALL LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ALREADY DO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THEIR COUNTIES
TOOK PAINS MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AND THEY SHIPPED WOULD
NOT ALTER THOSE PRE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS. ADDITIONALLY IN
RESPONSE TO CONTINUE ALLS FOR
THE FIELD FOR MORE COORDINATION
BETWEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
GENERAL EDUCATION PLANNING. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES TO
DEVELOP A SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADDENDUM TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. THAT
WOULD SUPPORT INCLUSIVE PLANNING
AND PROMOTE COHESION FINALLY
LINKING SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
GENERAL EDUCATION. EFFORT
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR SNYDER
. TO REFOCUS IN EXISTING SPECIAL
EDUCATION RESOURCE LEAVE ON- I
ET BEST PRACTICES BEGINNING IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AS
WELL AS ESTABLISH AN EXPERT
PANEL TO CONTINUE REFINING THE
MODEL I ET TEMPLATE THAT WAS
DEVELOPED AS PART OF A RECENT
WORKGROUP CONVENED BY THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES TO BUILD UON THE
ALTERNATE PATHWAYS TO DIPLOMAS
WORKGROUP EFFORTS BY EXPLORING
ALTERNATIVE FORCE BURKE OPTIONS
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
TO DEMONSTRATE COMPLETION OF THE
STATE GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS.
WHAT THAT'LL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
BUT BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE DO SEE THAT
YOUR COLLEAGUE IS GOING TO SO
SHE MAY BE ABLE TO HELP ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS AS WELL- MAKES
MORE MOVED TO. AND WE'RE DOING
QUESTIONS AFTER EVERY PANELIST
PRESENTS WERE MOVING TO EMILY
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. GOOD MORNING MR SHARE
SENATORS ANYWAY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SINCE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PROPOSALS UNDER THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ITEM I WILL JUST WALK
THROUGH THE ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
STARTING ON PAGE NINE OF YOUR
AGENDA- FIRST WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS THE PROPOSED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION.
AUGMENTATION WE THINK THIS IS A
PRUDENT WAY TO IN TO SPEND
INCREASE PROP NINETY EIGHT
FINDING AND ADDRESS THE LOCAL
COST PRESSURES RELATED TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION. NEXT TURNING
TO AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO MODIFY THE BASE RATE FORMULA.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WOULD CALCULATE
ATTENDANCE AT THE ALLEY A LEVEL
RATHER THAN A SCALPEL LEVEL JUST
AS A REMINDER IT SOMEPLACE OR
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN
AREAS. ARE REGIONAL CONSORTIA OF
ALLEY AS THAT COORDINATES
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES AND
FUNDING- LARGE DISTRICTS
TYPICALLY ACT AS THEIR OWN SELF
THAT. WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WHICH PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONING TO THE
SURPRISE THAT HAVE BOTH A MIX OF
GROWING AND DECLINING MEMBER
ALLEY AS- I'M JUST TO WALK.
THROUGH THIS IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL SO UNDER CURRENT LAW
A MEMBER DISTRICT WITH GROWING
ATTENDANCE COULD HAVE THEIR
GAINS OFFSET. IF ANOTHER MEMBER
DISTRICT HAS DECLINING
ATTENDANCE IN CONTRAST THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALLOWS ANY
ALLEGATION WITH ATTENDANCE
GROWTH IS ACTUALLY BLOCK IN
THAT- LIKE IN THAT ATTENDANCE
GROWTH AT THE L. A. LEVEL. AND
THAT GROWTH WOULD GENERATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING EVEN IF THE
SAMPLE OVERALL IS DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. AND WE DO KNOW THAT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BASED FUNDING WOULD CONTINUE TO
BE ALLOCATED AT THE SAMPLE
LEVEL. NEXT MOVING ONTO THE
PROPOSED ACTIVITIES RELATED TO
THE I. T. TEMPLATE AN ALTERNATE
PATHWAY TO DIPLOMA. WE FIND THAT
THESE PROPOSALS LACKS SPECIFIC
TIMELINES AND EXPECTATIONS.
BRING SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DOESN'T SPECIFY A DATE
BY WHICH THE ALTERNATIVE COURSE
WORK OR TNCS MUST BE FINALIZED-
BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO
TEACHERS. SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE
BE INTERESTED IN FINDING THESE
ACTIVITIES WE RECOMMEND IT
SPECIFY CLEAR DEADLINES AS WELL
AS REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
HELP THE LEGISLATURE MONITOR.
THE OUTCOMES OF THESE ACTIVITIES
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER SETTING IT'S- DEADLINE
. FOR THE STATE TO ADOPT SAY TO
WHY I KEEP TEMPLE IS A
LEGISLATURE IS INTEREST IN.
THESE CALLS. NEXT ARE MOVING ON
TO PROPOSAL TALLY BIG BANK
HEALTH. TO ALLEY RATHER THAN
SELF. WE SUGGEST ALLEGE. LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL ESPECIALLY HOW IT MIGHT
AFFECT REGIONALLY CORNY TO
PROGRAMS AND SCHOOL COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE WHICH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BEEN ENCOURAGING IN THE RECENT
YEARS. ALTHOUGH SOME SELLERS MAY
ALLOCATE TO MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS
DIRECTLY TO THEIR MEMBER ELLIE
AS- THERE ARE SOME SELFIES
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH SMALLER
LEDS THAT RETAIN THIS FINDING AT
THE SOFTWARE LEVEL. AND PROVIDE
THE SERVICES ON BEHALF OF ALL OF
THEIR ALLEY AS- IN THESE CASES
THE MEMBER ELOISE ARE TYPICALLY
TOO SMALL AND WHAT IT RECEIVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING ON THEIR OWN.
THE HIGHER MENTAL SENTIMENTAL
STAFF. AND PROVIDE THE SERVICES
ON OUR OWN. THIS WILL LOOK AT
ALL IMPACT SCHOOL. COUNTY MENTAL
PERMISSION- UNDER THIS
PARTNERSHIPS EXCEL BUT COULD
DIRECT THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING TO THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WHICH THEN
PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY. DISPOSAL COULD POSE
CHALLENGES FOR THESE
PARTNERSHIPS BY MAKING THESE
PROGRAMS. MORE ADMINISTRATIVELY
BURDENSOME SINCE COUNTIES BUT
THEN NEED TO ARRANGE SEPARATE
AGREEMENTS WITH EACH ELLIJAY OR
POTENTIALLY REDUCE TOTAL FINDING
F. AND ALLOCATE DECIDES TO PULL
FUNDING FROM THE PARTNERSHIP. IF
THEY DON'T FOR INSTANCE HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE PARTNERING WITH THE
COUNTY. THE LEGISLATURE ME JUST
WANT TO FURTHER EXPLORE WITH THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THIS
PROPOSAL ARCH INDETERMINATE
WHETHER THESE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH.
THE IMPACT THAT THESE COULD HAVE
ON THE REGIONAL PROGRAMS AND
PARTNERSHIPS. LASTLY WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS ON THE
PROPOSALS TO CONSOLIDATE THE
STATE'S TO EXISTING STRINGER
HOSPITALS INTO ONE. I'M DEVELOP
A SPECIAL EDUCATION ADDENDUM TO
THE ALL CAPS- AND- ESTABLISH AN
IPV AT BEST PRACTICES WE SOURCE
LEAD. I THINK ON THE LAST REPORT
WILL WE WILL JUST NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ME WANT TO REQUIRE
THE NEW RESOURCE LEAD TO BE
INVOLVED IN A DOUBLE UP ABOUT.
DEVELOPMENT OF THE C. WHITE IT
TEMPLATE JUST TO ENSURE THAT
STATEWIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
FROM THE AP IS. RESOURCE LEAD IS
ALIGNED WITH THE FINAL EIGHT P.
TEMPLATE- THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HOLDING QUESTIONS TILL
THE END. AND NOW WE'RE GOING. TO
MOVE TO ARM. HEATHER ADD. TO OF
A- AND IT'S THAT I'M BEING OVER
FROM I'M CAN TO GIVE YOU. MUCH
TO ME HOW PRONOUNCE YOUR LAST
NAME. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
HEATHER CALORIES ON THE DIRECTOR
OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. FROM
TODAY I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
. RECEIVE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENTS WILL ALLOW
FOR STRATEGIC AND SYSTEMIC
SHIFTS THAT WILL BENEFIT
STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. MUCH LIKE THIS YEAR'S
FISCAL PROPOSALS THIS YEAR'S
POLICY RELATED PROPOSALS ALSO
ALLOW FOR INCREASED
COLLABORATION AND TRANSPARENCY
AT ALL LEVELS OF OUR SYSTEM.
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN CD. AND
ELLIJAY THE PROPOSAL'S TAKES
STEPS TOWARDS ONE SYSTEM AND
ENSURE THAT THE VOICES OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THE PARENTS OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE CAPTURED DURING
THE SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT PROCESS.
WE'RE ESPECIALLY PLEASED TO KNOW
THAT TRANSITIONS WHETHER IT BE
THE ON RAMP TO SCHOOLING WHAT
ARE PARTS HE TO BE TRANSITION
WORK OR THE OFF RAMP WITH OUR
ALTERNATIVE PATHWAY WORK. CENTER
TO CRITICAL TIMES IN THE
STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
TRANSITIONS ARE SMOOTH AND
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR NOT ONLY A
MEANINGFUL EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO A MEANINGFUL
LIFE THAT INCLUDES VOICE AND
CHOICE. THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET WILL ALLOW US TO DEEPEN
OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES SUCH AS DIDI
ASKING DEAL ARE COUNTY OFFICES
EDUCATION SELFLESS AND ALSO IN
THE EIGHTIES. I THINK WE ALL
RECOGNIZE ADDRESSING. OUR SYSTEM
CHANGE MEANS THAT COLLABORATION
AT EVERY STAGE OF THE SYSTEM IS
THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS ASSISTING
IMPROVEMENT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE LEGISLATURE
OTHER PROPOSALS. MOVING FORWARD
AND HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
COMMENTS AND- I HAVE TO SAY
THAT. I AM WAGING A ONE PERSON
WORE ON ACRONYMS AND YOU MAY.
EVENTUALLY GET FOUR OF THEM IN
ONE SENTENCE THERE AND I THINK
WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT IN ONLY A
IS AND THERE WAS THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION BUT- WE'RE
GOING TO GET THERE SO THAT
PEOPLE LISTENING THAT AREN'T
FAMILIAR UNDERSTATEMENT. ARM ARE
GOING TO JUST READ WITH TWO
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I WANT TO GIVE
MY- COLLEAGUES A CHANCE TO ASK
QUESTIONS AS WELL. AND THE FIRST
ONE MAYBE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE A TO START. THE HOST
SINCE THE PROPOSAL CAME OUT. I
HEARD FROM THE LOCAL AGENCIES
THE CELL POSE. AND SO I WONDERED
IF YOU COULD JUST A LITTLE. MORE
CLEARLY EXPLAIN UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WHAT
THE NOTABLE DIFFERENCES MIGHT BE
AND THE ROLE THEY PLAY COMPARED
TO THEIR ROLE TODAY. AND I THINK
WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY LIST MIGHT
SO MAYBE THAT'S A DIRECT HER.
YES HI- THIS MIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO OUR PROPOSALS ARE NOT
AND- CURRENTLY TRYING TO CHANGE
ANY OF THE ROLES THAT SUBWAY.
WELL THAT'S A FASCINATING
RESPONSE- ONLY BECAUSE THEY ALL
THINK THAT THERE'S A CHANGE IS
IT BECAUSE OF CHANGE IN FUNDING
BUT NOT ROLES THAT I NOT ASKED
THE QUESTION CORRECTLY A WHY DO
THEY THINK THERE'S A CHANGE IN
WIDER DAY EXPRESSING. THEIR FREE
FLOATING ANXIETY OVER THE CHANGE
. SO FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING WHEN- THE
BUDGET WAS FIRST RELEASED AROUND
WHT I'M CALCULATING THE BASE
FUNDING AT THE L. E. LEVEL
ACTUALLY MEANT- YOU KNOW THAT-
SOME- SOME SALT IS. THOUGHT THAT
MEANT THAT WE WERE ALSO FLOWING
FUNDING TO ELEAZAR THAT'S NOT
THE CASE I KNOW THAT ANOTHER.
ASPECT THAT HAS BEEN- LIKE
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE HEARD IS
THE FLOWING OF THE EDUCATION
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING TO- TO ELEAZAR SELF US
AND STOP FUNDING IS NOT.
RESTRICTED TO JUST SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND I KNOW THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN CONCERNS THAT THIS
WOULD DISTRACT REGIONAL
STRUCTURES BUT WE DO NOTE THAT
THIS. PROPOSAL DOES NOT-
PRECLUDE ANY POOLING OF
RESOURCES OR- YOU KNOW BASICALLY
KEEPING THE STATUS QUO OF HOW
SERVICE DELIVERY IT IS BEING
MAINTAINED WE JUST WANT TO
ALIGN. THE FUNDING- STILL-HOW.
A FUNDING FLOWS IN AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT RESPONSE LET ME ASK THE
OTHER TWO PANELISTS OF EITHER OF
THEM HAVE A COMMENT ON. NOBODY
SAYING ANYTHING SO I'M GATHERING
THERE'S NO COMMENT. OKAY THEN I
HAVE ONE OTHER QUESTION. IN OUR
I THINK MAYBE START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SAFETY
OTHERS BECAUSE IN MY OWN OF
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT ARE
COMPARED TO THE LARGE URBAN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY'RE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW CAN. HOW CAN WE
PROTECT THE SMALLER DISTRICTS
FROM EXTENSIVE AMOUNTS OF
FUNDING ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
LITIGATION AND SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMS WHICH THEN GET
ALLOCATED TO THE DISTRICT FUNDS
N. AND I KNOW THAT- THAT ONE ONE
PARTICULAR DISTRICT I JUST HAD
OUT SIZED COSTS FOR ONE CASE IN
THEIR SMALLER DISTRICTS DIDN'T
REALLY COMPETES AGAINST.
CLASSROOM SERVICES AND OTHER
THINGS WHEN THAT HAPPENED SO- AT
A IS THERE SOMETHING WE CAN DO
TO PROTECT. DISTRICTS AND IN
THOSE SITUATIONS AND ONE EIGHT
S. FIRST WITH FINANCE AND SEE IF
ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO COMMENT. I
LIST MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
SO I CAN'T YOU KNOW CAN'T SPEAK
TO THE SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT
OCCURRED IN THE DISTRICT YOU'RE
REFERENCING BUT I WILL OTE THAT
THERE WASN'T INVESTMENT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. TO SUPPORT DISPUTE OF
PREVENTION INVOLUNTARY-
ALTERNATE DISPUTE RESOLUTION-
PRACTICES AND THIS IS BASICALLY
AIMED AT PROMOTING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS TO
PREVENT THE STATE FROM OCCURRING
OR ESCALATING AND THE FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I THINK
WHAT A WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL. IF
I CONNECT YOU WITH THAT DISTRICT
AND YOU COULD TALK TO THEM AND
THEN. I CAN TALK TO BOTH YOU AND
THEM AFTERWARDS TO SEE IF THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THAT WE THINK
WAS A SOLUTION. AND IN FACT WAS%
A SOLUTION THEY DIDN'T REALIZE
IT BORTON FACT WAS NOT A
SOLUTION AND IT BRINGS US BACK
TO THE QUESTION OF. HOW TO TRY
TO HELP THEM SO I KNOW I AM A
STAFF MEMBER VERY CAREFULLY
TAKING NOTES RIGHT NOW AND I'M
TRYING TO HOOK YOU IN THE
DISTRICT UP TO PURSUE THAT. ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM EITHER
THE L. A. OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON THAT. OF FOR THOSE
OF YOU FOLLOWING AT HOME THEY
BOTH SHOOK THEIR HEADS- SO LET'S
MOVE TO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- SENATOR OR
TROUBLED DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. NONE AND SENATOR
MINUTES TEMPORARY LEFT ROOM
LET'S HOPE THAT HE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS- SO. THEN ONE MAY
ASK ONE MORE AND MAYBE HE'LL
HAVE ONE WHEN HE COMES BACK AND
A. N. THAT IS ONE THAT'S CALLED
OUT IN THE AGENDA THAT- FOR
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
WHO FAMILIES OF ELECTED TO KEEP
THEM HOME DURING THE PANDEMIC.
OR HAD TO QUARANTINE DUE TO CODE
NINETEEN EXPOSURE OR INFECTION.
WHAT TYPES OF SUPPORTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
LEARNING LOSS. IF ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROPOSED
WOULD BE TARGETED TOWARD THOSE
TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS AND LET'S
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. MY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AYE I'LL SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT TEAM THE FUNDING ASPECT OF
THAT THERE IS- NOTHING SPECIFIC
TO THAT- AND SPECIFIC TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION CURRENTLY PROPOSED IN
THE BUDGET BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED. FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT ONE TIME TO PROVIDE
LEARNING RECOVERY SUPPORT FOR
PEOPLES WITH DISABILITIES AND
RELATED TO THE COULD BE NINETEEN
DESTRUCTIONS AND THE FUNDS ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE-
AND I EXPECT. SANTIAGO HEATHER
CALUMNIES AT THE DEPARTMENT TO
MAYBE ANSWER. AS AND AS WAS
MENTIONED AS WELL THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ALLOCATION FOR
UPLOADING LOST- IS. ONE THAT
CURRENTLY- IS YOU KNOW AGAIN
ALLEYWAYS ARE- YOU KNOW. THE
FUNDS MUST BE ENCUMBERED TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- EACH FAMILY AID MUST HAVE
YOU KNOW OUR STUDENTS A LEARNING
RECOVERY PLAN- BUT TO CD AND SO
- OUR TEAM HAS- OKAY ON
SUPPORTING AND ALSO- INSURING-
THE ALLEY IS HAVE THE RIGHT
REQUISITE SUPPORT- THAT THEY
NEED FROM C. OR OTHER- ENTITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AS OUR SOFTWARE
PROVEN LEADER STATEWIDE SYSTEM
SUPPORT AS WELL- AND SO WHAT WE
- HAVE BEEN. IN TERMS OF PATTERN
TREND IN TERMS OF THOSE. THE
ONES ARE BEING USED- I'M- SO. IN
OF THE- AND SUPPLIES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. ON THE
HIRING STAFF TO WELL- AND SO-
YOU KNOW IF YOU WE ARE. VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR- WITH OUR
ALLEYS ACROSS A THIS ACROSS THE
EXPENSE GOALS. I DIDN'T WANT
MENTION IS WELL TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT ALSO. ASSEMBLY
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING- TO
PROVIDE. ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT
TO LOCAL EDUCATION EDUCATION
AGENCIES IN DEVELOPING AND
ADMINISTERING COMPREHENSIVE.
PEACE IN TO DEVELOP TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO ASSESS AND ADDRESS
LEARNING AND SERVICE NEEDS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES- FROM
COMPLICATIONS OR DIFFICULTIES
STEMMING FROM CORPORATE NINETEEN
DURING- THAT THAT TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. SCHOOL YEAR AS
WELL- AND SO- CVD ISSUED
GUIDANCE ON THE WE ALSO. HAVE UP
FOR. SOME OF THE CROSSES TO ALL
. WORK LOCALLY AND LAST QUESTION
TO ALL HELP. A SUPPORT TO SWAP.
THANK YOU- DOES L. A. AND IN THE
- COMMENT THAT ALL. AND THAT IT
TIME THE MISTER J. OKAY THANK.
ARE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS WE ON
. SEEING NONE OF. I DON'T WANT
OF. DID THE QUICKNESS WITH WHICH
WE WENT THROUGH THAT TO BE
MISTAKEN FOR HOW SERIOUSLY WE
TAKE IT A. N. HOW MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO LOOK AT THESE
PROPOSALS OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FLUSHED OUT AND AT WORK AND ARE
THAT WHEN WE GET TO THE MAY
REVISE AND MAY WE- KNOW WE MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE LIVING UP TO
THE TO WHAT THEY'RE REPRESENTED
A TO BE BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE- THE PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE THIS IS- AN ITEM OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
THIRD AND LAST ITEM. OUR ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY WHICH IS FUNDING
FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
AND ACCESS PROPERTY TAX. INTO
THIS IS A WHO LAID OUT IN THE
AGENDA IT IS ABOUT A- HISTORIC
YOU SHOOT THIS IS JUST
INFORMATIONAL. AND THE TWO
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL OR EDGAR
CABRAL FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. AND EARNED A
READY OF FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WARM WE'LL BEGIN
WITH MR CABRAL. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE GROUP
BOTH A ANALYST'S OFFICE. I HAVE
A GOOD SUMMARY THE ISSUE IS-
HOEKSTRA. A BRIEFING. OF WHAT
THE ISSUE IS A TRADING POINT IN
- WITH US WE ARE THE- THE TO THE
OF HELP YOU START WITH MEANS SO
I THANK YOU FOR PAYING ATTENTION
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL. DEMOCRATS
ARE PRETENDING IT PUBLIC ALSO
THE FOR WHAT ACTORS. TALK ME. A
TRIPLE PLAY. TO OFFICE PROJECT
AND SCHOOLS. THE J. BOTH- COMING
OF WITH THE KIDS AND SCHOOL. ARE
THERE. FUNDING FORMULA THE LOWER
CONTROL FORMULA. THE FORMULA OF
THE LITTLE DIFFERENT FOR COUNTY
OFFICE BUT IT YOU HAVE THIS IN
GENERAL IDEA YOUR DESPITE
FUNDING. AND THEN WITH THE STATE
DOES THE IT LOOKS HOW MUCH LOCAL
TAX. THE ENTITY RECEIVING AND
THE- DIFFICULT TO PROTECT TAXES
ARE BASED ON SORT OF FREE
PROPERTY. OF FUNDING AND
WHATEVER AMOUNT IS- EVAN
REMAINING TO THE DISTRICT NEEDS
OR TRAVIS. YEAH FOR FORMULA OF
THE- ARE REQUIRED TO RECEIVE AND
THAT'S BOTH PROPERTY TAXES ARE
WHAT WE CALL ACCESS PROPERTY
TAXES THERE ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT'S- NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
YOUR FEEDBACK. THE PRODUCT FOR
SCHOOL THIS BETTER PROPER TAX
THEY LADY ARE. GET TO KEEP A USE
LOCAL YOU WHATEVER PRAYER THEY
HAVE- COUNTY OFFICES MEETING.
NOT BE NOT AUTHORIZE TO SPEND A
FROM TAXES. ON THE FUNDING FOR-
A LONG TIME WAS A TYPICALLY IN
CA OF WHAT OVER. I DON'T THIRD
WAS BIG USED TO COVER UP THE FOR
WHATEVER COULD FUNDING THE ONE-
INFO WHEN YOU'RE- I WOULD BE IN
THE TWENTY TWO THERE WAS A WAY
TIME TAX. IN TWENTY ELEVEN AND
IN TWENTY FORTY A PIC OF MORE
PERMIT ON. A CHANGE WAS TO TAKE
THE ACCESS PROPERTY TAXES FROM
COUNTY OPPOSITE. IN YOUR DOES
ARE DIRECTLY GO TO THE WITH THE
TO. THE SUPERIOR COURT OF BETTER
IN. EACH COUNTY IN THE COUNTY
THAT HAVE. TO- THAT WAS A BIG
THAT WAS A GOOD NET EFFECT THAT
IS BY STATE GENERAL FUND SOME OF
THIS. CAN REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND THAT FOR THE TRUCK
WITH SYSTEM. BECAUSE IT IT
HAPPENED THAT YOU HAVE LESS
GENERAL CONTRIBUTIONS ARE
REQUIRED. NUMBER HAS INCREASED
OVER TIME AND SO THAT'S PART OF
WHAT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
INCREASE. BUT AGAIN THAT THE NET
EFFECT OF THE OF THE POLICY- THE
RECENT POLICY CHANGE RIGHT NOW
I'M NOT A RESERVE BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN ALMOST TEN YEARS BUT THAT
THAT CHANGE. RESULTED IN THE
STATE BEING ABLE TO CAPTURE
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH- WITH PROTECTIVE TAXES- IT
DIDN'T NEED ANY CHANGES FOR
WHAT. COUNTY OFFICES CAN DO KIND
OF REMEMBER ALLOWED TO STEP BACK
EXISTS ON IN THE ACTIVITY. ON
TOP OF THE WATER IN APPEARANCE
OF THE- AND LET ME ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
READY. IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD TO THAT. ONE RESEARCHER
AGAIN IN A OR IF- I DO. HAVE
ANYTHING DOWN TO- AND YOUR
COMMENTS I DON'T REALLY DO. IF
EITHER I THINK YOU SOME UP- THE
ISSUE. QUITE SINGLING AND I
AGREE THAT THE GEN. ITEM ALSO
UNDER DETAILED AND OUT I DON'T.
HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH ITS- BUT
HAPPY. ANSWER QUESTIONS. ARE WE
HOPE THAT- DEAL CALM. SAYING YOU
DON'T HAVE. WITH THE AGENDA
SECTOR ON A ITEM SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT ONE- THEN. IF YOU
. ARE BOTH INDULGE ME. ARM I'D
LIKE TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS AND
ACTUALLY. IN A WAY THAT I THINK
YOU ACTUALLY. OUR OF MOSTLY
ANSWERED SOME OF THEM BUT JUST A
DIRT CLEARLY MAYBE I'LL START
WITH MR CABRAL AND JUST EVER SEE
IF MR READY IT HAS THINGS THAT
HE WISHES TO ADD BUT- YOU
MENTIONED THAT- IT'S A HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IS
THE TOTAL OF THE- OF THE ACCESS
AND THAT. FIFTY FIVE ACROSS SO
ALIVE IN FACT COUNTIES AND
THAT'S UP SUBSTANTIALLY FROM THE
ORIGINAL AMOUNT THAT WAS DONE IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN OR TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHATEVER THAT WAS SET
CORRECT. CORRECT I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHAT THE AMOUNT WAS-
ORIGINALLY I THINK THE BUT I
BELIEVE- IT WAS IT WAS IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF THINK IT WAS
MORE IT IS CLOSER TO FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- AND THEN SINCE
THEN WE'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE THE PROPERTY TAX BY
USERS USE. OF YOU KNOW AND SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO THE
TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION I
BELIEVE UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET IDEA THE FINDINGS OF THE
MISSING THING LIKE A HUNDRED
TWENTY BILLION FOR THE BUDGET.
AND THEN- YOU MENTIONED ALIVE
AND COUNTIES AND AT THAT NUMBER
HAD GROWN- SO ORIGINALLY IT WAS
A SMALLER NUMBER OF COUNTIES
LIKE FOR FIVE MINUTES MOVED TO
ELEVEN ROUGHLY. YEAH THANKS FOR
THE CHARACTER OF THE EXACT
NUMBER OF COUNTIES INITIALLY
WHEN THIS WHEN THIS WAS AN
ACTIVE BUT IF IT BECAUSE THAT WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
COUNTIES WITH KNOWLEDGE AND
THEN- IS THERE A WAY TO
CHARACTERIZE THE ELEVEN COUNTIES
AND WHAT I MEAN IS. IS IF IT'S
ELEVEN COUNTIES THAT HAVE ACCESS
PROPERTY TAX MONEY DO THESE TEND
TO BE COUNTIES THAT HAVE HIGH
AMOUNTS. OF- PROCESSED PROPERTY
VALUE AND THE REASON. A MEAN
THIS IS. WE WERE NEXT TO FIND A
WHOLE HOST OF ZERO NEVADA
COUNTIES AND WE BE MORE FOR SO
WORKS CLARA I KNOW ONE AND OTHER
PRICE VALUE COUNTY IS THAT A
FAIR STATEMENT DO YOU THINK-
GENERALLY FOR IT WITH ALL
PROPERTY TAX RELATED THINGS BUT
YOU ALWAYS COME UP WITH QUIRKS.
YOU KNOW PART OF THE BE FUN HOW
MY- WHAT'S OF PROPERTY TAXES
WERE PROVIDED TO EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHEN PROPERTY WITHIN ACTED
IN BOTH THOSE SHARES HAVE BEEN
FROZEN IN TIME SO. I THINK THERE
MIGHT BE SOME HIGHER PROPERTY
VALUE COMPANIES THAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO BE ON THIS LIST BUT
MAYBE ARE NOT BECAUSE OF THOSE.
FOR THOSE REASONS BUT IN
GENERAL- IT YOURSELF THAT'S
CORRECT- THE COUNTIES WHO TEND
TO BE ON THIS LIST I BELIEVE
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE IN TERMS OF
THE DOLLAR VALUE OF THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING THAT. EXTRA FRIENDLY
ROUGHLY HALF IT COMES FROM SAN
MATTEO IN SANTA CLARA. AND SOLD
SUBJECT IT IT IT DOESN'T TO BE
RELEASED TO COUNTY SAN HAVE. IT
TURNS OUT HIRED A COUPLE ROLE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. VERY MUCH THAT
AND THEN ALSO. THE ASSEMBLY
COUNTIES THE MALLOY THAT THEY
HAVE JUST RETURNED TO ADD.
RATHER THAN OTHER CALL. REFER TO
IT AS IT THAT WAS DONE AT THE
HIGH OF THE- MELT- AND LYFT IN
PLACE THE I DON'T WANT YOU TO.
HAVE TO ON THE CASE A OF BY IT
WAS A- DONE A TIME THE BUDGET
WAS STRUCK IN TENS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS DEFICIT DID WORKING
FOR EVERY. OF PLACE TO TRY TO
DRAW. FROM IS THAT PROBABLY AN
ACCURATE STATEMENT. I THINK
THAT'S HER MOTHER INITIAL THE
FIRST YEAR THAT IT WAS DONE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT INTO ELEVEN WHEN
THE STATE WAS IN IN A PRETTY ARE
. I WAS SORT OF RIGHT BEFORE-
THE PASSAGE OF PROP THIRTY AS
REVENUES TO COME TICKET
SOMETHING THAT BOB OF OUR- JUST
TO- THINK. I THINK I'M- BUT WE
GOT TO THIRTEEN FORTY MINUTES
WAS IN A ON A PER BASIS I DON'T
KNOW I WOULD CHARACTERIZED FACT
THAT WAS THE- ANYMORE- I WOULD
SAY ALSO. PART OF WHY IT.
PROVIDED YOUR- A COMMUNITY AN
OPTION BUT THE THING THAT HAS.
LOOKED BACK COUNTY. PROPERTY TAX
THE GIVEN AND OTHER. SUPPORT
THESE FIND ARE A PEOPLE. IS
STRICTLY WITH THE- THERE IS SOME
SPECIALIST. FROM THAT IS COMES
FROM PROPERTY TO VALUE. BETTER
FROM YOU STILL- THE PRACTICE OF
FINDING IDENTIFIED OTHER WAYS
TO. THAT FUNDING BE I- DURING
THAT. PIECES B. R. THE TIME. OF
FOR MOST OF. I THINK IT HAS
SOMETHING OF THE STATE HAS. IN
THE PREVIOUS YEARS. AND I THINK
. THAT. AND I THINK YOU ANSWERED
THIS QUESTION BUT LET ME JUST
REEMPHASIZE IT. ARM IF FOR ANY
REASON MONEY WORK TO BE ABLE
FROM THE ACCESS TAXES GO TO THE-
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. THERE
WOULD HAVE TO BE A LIKE AMOUNT
OF MONEY APPROPRIATED FOR THE
EXPENDITURES THAT WERE DISPLACED
BY THAT HAPPENING WOULD THAT BE
CORRECT. RIGHT NOW THIS THIS
PROVIDES FUND FEEDING FOR THE
STATE TO COME THE STATE COURT
COSTS SO IF THE IF FUNDING WERE
NO TO BE YOU IN THIS WAY THE
STATE WOULD TO BACK OUT UNDER
AND FIFTY OR NOT HUNDRED GROW
TURN TABLE. WITH GENERAL. TO
COVER THOSE COSTS AND YOU
INDICATE THE BECAUSE THERE'D
BEEN QUESTION ABOUT SOME OF THE
COUNTY. PEOPLE THAT THIS MONEY
ACTUALLY DOES NOT. OUT OF THE
COUNTY THAT IF IT WAS COLLECTED
AS PROPERTY TAX WITHIN A COUNTY
GOES TO COURT RATHER EXPENSES
THAT ARE WITHIN THAT COUNTY IT.
DOESN'T MOVE AROUND SAID CORRECT
. MIKE DO YOU. THINK FROM. OUR
THE COMING. I BELIEVE THAT. THE
POLITICS OF THE CALL BEFORE.
RATHER ARE GOING TO FONG- THE
FUNDING IS TRYING TO THERE THEN
THEN THE TO BELIEVE IF YOU GO.
BEING TRANSFERRED TO THE TO THE
COURTS TO FOR TWENTY. FROM THE
TH STATE'S PERSPECTIVE IT NOT
COMING TO THIS AND STATE
DIVISION PROFESSOR WAY. I'VE
BEEN REMAINS ALL OF LOCAL. BACK
WAS CREATED SEVERAL YEARS AGO
FOR A VARIETY OF OTHER OF ACTIVE
LIKE THIS. WERE FUNDS WOULD BE
USED LOOK. AMERICA STABLE MEANS
THAT THE- MY THAT. YOU TO BE
SPENT ON THE TRUCK WERE WITH
THEM AS- THE- WILL. THEIR
RECORDS. IN THE COUNTIES RECEIVE
LESS GENERAL. BECAUSE THE
RECEIVING TAX DOESN'T HAVE ANY
IMPACT. FOR THE COURTS OF THE
MISSING NET HE IN THE AMOUNT OF
ALSO TO. HAS MOVED AMONG CAN PER
PROP TAXES JOHN AND THEN NEXT
QUESTION MAY BE UNDER. PLONGEON
THE WE BUT OF. THE IT TERMS OF
WHAT I MEANI GUESS I CAN SEE
IF. THE FUNDING. I THINK THE WAY
WE NEED TO DO IT THERE WHEN HE
WAS SORT OF STAYED IN THE CAMP
OF THE COPIER. WE COUNTY ALSO
THE- SO ASSEMBLY. HAVE WOULD BE
ABLE RECORD INTEREST DON'T. I
DON'T THINK OF THE BIG. INTEREST
ON THEIR NEVER A- THAT. FOR MY
ANDERSON. NOT AND- SOMETHING
THOSE SPECIFICALLY CONCERT WHEN
Y. OF. THE FUNDING WOULD MOVE.
OUT TO OUR- TO THE- FOR GENERAL
TAKES FOR COURTS. I WITH. I DO
IS JUST SORT OF A FACT. MATTER
WHETHER THAT. TRUE AND I'D- THAT
. AND THEN LASTLY. IT. I PASS.
SOME OF THE COW IN QUESTION IF
THEY WOULD. INDICATE WHAT THEY
SPEND THE MONEY IF- IF- IT IT
TURNS OUT THAT THAT THEY WERE UP
FOR COMPETITION WITH THE- WITH
THE OTHER FUNDS AND SO I THINK
D. A. OBVIOUSLY IN THE TWO
COUNTIES THAT YOU MENTIONED. OF
THE THEY FEEL. STRONGLY THAT
THIS MONEY IS BEING DIVERTED
AWAY FROM LOCAL EDUCATION USES
IN IT TO END AND HAVE STRONG
CONCERNS ABOUT IT. AND SO I
THINK THIS DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
REALLY HEALTHY BECAUSE IT TALKS
ABOUT HOW THIS ISSUE IS GROWN
TALKS ABOUT THE COUNTIES. IT
DRESSES THE ISSUE THAT'S THEIR
CONCERN OF WHETHER OR NOT THIS
WAS A GIMMICK OR WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
REPLACED OVER TIME- IT IT. MAKES
CLEAR THAT OTHER THINGS WOULD
HAVE TO BE FUNDED BURKE FOR THE
DISPLACED COSTS. ARE IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE MONEY GOES TO THE
COUNTIES NOW- AND IT'S ALSO
CLEAR THAT AT LEAST THOSE TWO
COUNTIES PROBABLY. OR MORE WELL
TO DO THAT SOME OTHER COUNTIES
THAT IS IT THIS MIGHT BE
HAPPENING TO OR NOT. AND THE
ISSUE OF INTEREST SEEMS OPEN.
AND THEN. IT HE I HAD ASKED THEM
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY MIGHT
SPEND THE MONEY ON IF IN FACT.
IT WERE NOT DIVERTED BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
POLICY FINDING THAT THAT IS
COMPETITIVE WITH THE OTHER
EXPENDITURES AND SO. THERE'S
JUST STRONG CONCERN ABOUT THIS
AND SOME OF THE COUNTIES WHERE
THIS IS GOING ON AND- AND THE
IRONY IS THAT. IF IN FACT. THIS
IS WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF THE
STATE TO DO AND THEN THE STATE
IS WEIGHING THINGS OF IMPORTANCE
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS WHETHER
IT'S COURTS AND ACCESS. MIGHT
IRONICALLY MAKE A CASE FOR
MOVING SOME OF IT OUT OF THE
COUNTY OF ORIGIN AND EQUALIZING
GET THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
EDUCATION. OUR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ACROSS THE STATE IN A
WAY THAT THAT IF THE STATE IS
PRIORITIZING IT THAT HAPPENS
BUT- I THINK THEY'LL BE
CONTINUED TALK ABOUT THIS AND
THEIR STRONG CONCERN IN SOME
COUNTIES. AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
JUST IMPORTANT FOR US TO AGENDA
I SAID HAVE A DISCUSSION AIRED
IN THE LIGHT OF DAY AND BE AWARE
OF. OF THE CONCERNS THAT EXIST
FROM THOSE ELEVEN COUNTIES SO. I
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM EITHER
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS- CENTER
ROADSHOW BOAT THANK YOU- IT'S A
REALLY GOOD QUESTION DO WE HAVE
ANY OF THESE COUNTIES- WE GIVE
ANY INFORMATION OR ANY
OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT OR
FEEDBACK. OR DID YOU HAVE A
PERSONAL CONVERSATION WITH THEM
ARE BELIEVE ME THEY HAVE HAD
PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH ME
OKAY. THEY WERE AND THEN THE
ENGINE AND I KNOW THAT. I'M BY
NO THAT- I BELIEVE IT'S THE
CAPITAL VISORS FIRMS WORKING ON.
THIS HAS HAD A MEETING WITH
FINANCE AND OTHER PEOPLE TO
RAISE THESE ISSUES OKAY BUT LAST
YEAR IT CAME UP AT THE END OF
OUR BUDGET PROCESS. WITHOUT
THERE HAVING BEEN ANY DISCUSSION
ALONG THE WAY AND SO THIS YEAR I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT. TO
HAVE THE DISCUSSION SO IF THIS
CONTINUES AS THE DISCUSSION IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS WE ARE FULLY
AIRED THE ISSUES IN A WAY. THAT
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THEM AND I
THINK IT'S VERY HARD. FOUR OF
THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY WHERE
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY
REALLY VIEW IT AS SOMETHING THAT
NORMALLY WOULD COME THEIR WAY.
AND YET ARE. IN ONE COUNTY
THAT'S AFFECTED. LAST YEAR. WHEN
IT WAS RAISED AT THE END OF THE
BUDGET SESSION I HEARD FROM
COUNTY GOVERNMENT WHO'S
INCREDIBLY CONCERNED IT WOULD BE
A CUT TO THEIR COURT SYSTEM. THE
END SO ALL THOSE DYNAMICS AROUND
THEIR- AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT THAT EVERYBODY BE
AWARE OF THE MEN IF THERE IS A
HARD TO BE ANY CHANGE OVER TIME
OF ANY KIND WE WOULD'VE HEARD IT
VERY CLEARLY AND WE WOULD HAVE
WEIGHED THE PROS AND CONS HOW IT
WORKS. AND WHAT THE TRADE OFFS
ARE THAT'S WHAT WE JUST DID.
BRIGITTE THAT NOW THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ASKING. ARE THERE
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON THE SIDE
OF. THEN WE APPRECIATE BOTH OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE. OUR THAT
COMPLETES THE THREE PANELS WE
HAVE. AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF
THE ITEMS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
TODAY HE'S NOT GOING TO JUDGE IN
THE SECOND HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WAITING. SO TODAY'S PARTICIPANTS
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. END OF IF
IT EN ROUTE LET ME FIRST WELCOME
THE MODERATOR- MODERATOR YOU
WITH THIS YEAR. THANK YOU MISTER
TERRIFY HIM WELL THANK YOU AND-
I THINK THAT. WE WOULD LIKE TO.
MAKE SURE WE'RE DONE BY ELEVEN
FIFTEEN AND SO I'M GOING TO
LIMIT IT TO ONE MINUTE BUT IF IT
TURNS OUT MORE PEOPLE LINE UP.
BECAUSE THEN WILL WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF FOR SO- LET'S GO TO OUR
CALLERS AND IF YOU COULD GIVE ME
A HINT- OF HOW MANY CALLERS
THERE ARE IN QUEUE AS WE START
TO APPRECIATE. ABSOLUTELY I'LL
GO AHEAD AND JUST THE STATE THE
- WISHING TO COMMENT TODAY ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR MIND
THEM AND ONE OF MY NUMBER'S
CALLED THE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION BEFORE COMMENTING.
AND IT- AND WE DO HAVE OUR ARM
SORRY GO AHEAD I SURE DIDN'T
WANT TO. INTERRUPT THAT. OKAY
ACTUALLY WE DO HAVE EIGHT IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PERFECT OF
THE ONE THING I SKIPPED IS I'D
JUST BEFORE WE GO TO YOUR
MODERATOR I NEED TO GIVE- THE
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WHAT TALK AND
LIKE SEE AT LEAST ONE AND MAYBE.
TWO SO- IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM RUSHERS TO ADDRESS TO
COMMITTEE POLICE WALKED TO THE
MICROPHONE AND- STATE YOUR AME
AND YOU HAVE UP TO A MINUTE. TO
ADDRESSES WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MARK ABSTAINED CALIFORNIAN
VIA EMAIL TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
NETWORK. AND I WANNA- BASICALLY
GO BACK A LITTLE BIT FROM LAST
WEEK'S HEARING MY COMMENTS ABOUT
DIGITAL SKILLS AND LINK BACK TO
THE DISCUSSION ON. INDEPENDENT
STUDY IN CENTER MAN'S COMMENTS
ABOUT- SHORT TERM ACTIONS
CREATING LONG TERM PROBLEMS. ARE
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO HE'S WITH
OUR WEB GIS PROGRAM. AS WE WERE
MAKING A TRANSITION FROM DOING
IN PERSON WORKSHOPS PULLOUT'S AT
SCHOOL SITES TO GOING TO ONLINE.
AND CREATING ON DEMAND- VIDEOS I
STARTED- PROMOTING A
RECOMMENDING TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. OF DEVELOPING BLACK
HOLDEN BANKS RECALL THEM
LIBRARIES. OF- OF AS FAR AS
INSTRUCTIONAL VIDEO TO BE UP FAR
AS I'M TO YOU TO CHANNEL TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS FOR BOTH
MULTI DAY ABSENCES AND REMEDIAL
INSTRUCTION. AND I WOULD YOU
KNOW YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER
THINKING ABOUT SOME FUNDING OR
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE THAT MIGHT ALLEVIATE THE
PROBLEM THAT WAS BEING DISCUSSED
ABOUT SHORT TERM ENROLLMENT AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY. THANK YOU I
LET YOU GO A LITTLE OVER TO
COMPLETE YOUR THOUGHT BUT IT'S A
GOOD- REMINDER. I'D JUST TO
EVERYONE THAT WE WILL ALLOW YOU
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TIME. TODAY TO
TESTIFY OR- YOU CAN'T SAY AT ALL
WITHIN THE BRIEF TIME THAT'S
ALLOTTED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS TO US WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO RECEIVE. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM A WISH TO ADDRESS TO
COMMITTEE. R. THEN MODERATOR
WE'RE BACK TO YOU- LET'S GO TO
OUR CALLERS. THANK YOU AND WE DO
HAVE AN ELEVEN IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM A LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
HALFPENNY MOCKED CST A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CARE PROFESSIONALS
WE WANT TO FIRST THANK THE CARE
MEMBERS STAFF. ANALYST IN THE
PHONE MODERATORS FURTHER.
INFORMATIVE AND WELL ORGANIZED
DURING. WE WANT TO ECHO THE
PANELISTS FROM GILROY NOTING THE
LACK OF STAFF DUE TO LOW WAGES
THOSE WERE HER EXACT WORDS BUT
THE LACK OF WAGES TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN EDUCATORS AND PARA
PROFESSIONALS MUST. BE ADDRESSED
IF WE WANT TO EDUCATE. OUR
STUDENTS AT ANY HOUR OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT
KOHLER. NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
MORNING JESSICA FALCO ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW RELATIVE TO THE
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS- WE
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT WOULD
LEAD TO AN EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS PROVIDE SAFE PLACES FOR
KIDS OF WORKING FAMILIES TO GO
BEFORE AND AFTER SCHOOL AND
DURING THE SUMMER. THEY
PROVIDING RICHMOND CONNECTED TO
THE SCHOOL DAY SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT TUTORING MEALS AND
SNACKS AND MORE ARE YOU WHAT DO
THE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONSIDER INCORPORATING
ROBUST REPORTING AND EVALUATION
COMPONENT AS WELL AS CONSIDER IF
THE FUNDING PROVIDED VIA THIS
PROGRAM IS SUFFICIENT. TO
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SERVICE OUR KIDS DESERVE
INCLUDING CLARIFICATIONS ON WHAT
THE YOU PUT UP YOUR BILL RATE
IS. MUCH LIKE THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OF EXPANDED LEARNING WORK FORCE
WHETHER EMPLOYED BY AN LED OR A
COMMUNITY BASED PARTNER AND AS
THE STATE SEEKS TO EXPAND THE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
PROGRAM CONSIDER INVESTMENTS IN
THE WORK FORCE PREPARATION AND
RETENTION AS WELL AS TO HOW TO
IMPORT POTENTIALLY INCORPORATE
THIS WORK FORCE INTO THE
TRADITIONAL T. K. TWELVE
CLASSROOM. TEACHER PIPELINE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NECK CALL. NINE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION.
ULTIMATELY ONE ADULT MADE BY
THOSE BEFORE ME- SHORT TERM
INVESTMENTS AND TIME FUNDING HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANT CAUSE FOR WHY
WE HAVE A WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND
THE BEST WAY TO ADDRESS OUR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION AND BY
INVESTING DOLLARS INCREASING
WAGES INCREASING BENEFIT- THAT
BEING SAID WE ARE SUPPORTED CAN
ACTUALLY OF THE IRAQ HELLO WE
NEED IMPORTANT TO UTILIZE
EXISTING PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE. FOCUSED HE SAID
WOULD AUTHORED A MUCH IN EVERY
EFFORT TO PRIORITIZE THE WELL
AND PROBABLY EMPLOYEE OFFERING
MORE OUR FOR WORK IS CRITICAL TO
INCREASING CRIMINAL. AND KNOW
THOSE PROGRAMS AND HOW GREATER
AT THE TIME OF DEDICATE STAFF
AND WE ARE PRE OF A NEW DOLLARS
RUN EDUCATE BUT WHEN EXACTLY
THAT AERATION ADDITION DOLLARS
IN FOR MY TO SEVERELY HAVE COSTS
. THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH PER
SHARE YOUR CON MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE TWENTY FIVE JULY IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
LAST YEAR'S RETURN ONCE THIS AND
OTHERS REGARDING WALKED FIRST
THANKS FOR ROBUST PUBLIC
DISCUSSION SECOND THE DOES
DISTRICTS CAN YOU THAT ALL
PURPOSE THE- DIFFICULT. TAKING
YOU OF SCALE EVEN IN THE CURRENT
AND BY WHICH WILL GET WORSE NOW
YEAR IN THE BILL PROPOSED A NEW
EXPAND STOP ADVANCED BRAKE.
FINDING MORE TEN YOU CAN GIVEN
TO THE FUNDING LAW SO IT'S
UNCERTAIN OF IT DOUBLED ABLE NAY
. EXACT KALTER LESS THAN FIVE
YOU. THANK WE NEED ONLY ABOUT
SEVEN AND FORTY DOLLARS FOR
OTHER STUDENTS AT THAT DISTRICT
OF THE STATE PARTISAN. I THINK
PERCENT STAKE WHAT PART OF
DEPENDING CHEN ALL THE THIRTY ON
DOLLARS. TARGET PLAN AROUND THEN
THERE'S THE PERVERSE CONSEQUENCE
OF THE ENFORCED CORLEY. BETWEEN
THE PERCENT ALL OF STUDENTS ARE
AND ON THE RECEIPT FOR EACH.
ONLY BE MORE CREATURES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- MODERATOR
NEXT KOHLER. NINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MICHELLE MCKAY UNDERWOOD CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR ITEMS TO. SUPPORT
THE MEXICAN FUNDING INCREASED
RESIDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
HOWEVER DESPITE THE PROPOSED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WE BELIEVE SOME
DISTRICTS WILL RECEIVE FEWER
SPECIAL EDUCATION DOLLARS NEXT
YEAR COMPARED WITH THIS YEAR AND
THIS YEAR'S ONE TIME CULTURALLY
DEFINED BUT YOU HEARD ABOUT OUR
MODELS. RAPPLER DEFECTOR TO
ENSURE THAT NO ALLOCATE REFUSE
YOU WERE SPECIAL EDUCATION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE BY INCREASING THE
PER ADA AMOUNT FROM THE PROPOSED
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS. TO
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FOR
A- WE ARE VERY. ABOUT THE LEAD.
OF RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FROM CELLPHONE. NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS A
GREAT. DIFFICULTY NINETEEN CAN.
I WORK FOR DIFFICULT THE TRUCK
CRITIC IMPORTANT SO THAT THE A-
COSTS TO ENSURE THE LAST. NEXT
MONTH I FUNDING THE LIMIT FOR OF
PROVIDING THE REGIONAL SERVICE.
FINALLY REGARDING THE FRESH
INTERESTS- THEM WE BELIEVE ALL
L. A. IS NOT A SOMETHING THAT WE
- SHOULD FULLY AND- THE- OUTCOME
OF. WITH THE- BY COMPLETING
PROPOSED KAPPA NUMBER STUDENTS
TO THIS ABOUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COM. MODERATOR MEXICO. BLIND TO
SIX. YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FLOCK REP THE RIVER THANK IF YOU
COULD OF SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY
THREE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT IN THE COUNTY MY
COMMENTS PERTAIN TO THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOALS OF
THE PROGRAM AND WE THINK
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY OFFERED
IN THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BUT AS I THINK WAS
EVIDENT FROM YOUR DISCUSSION
THIS MORNING THERE ARE LOCAL
CHALLENGES FOR MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION TO THOSE
OUTLINED BY MR FONG I WOULD ADD
THE SIMPLE FACT THAT JUST
KEEPING SCHOOLS OPEN AND
OPERATING IN RECENT MONTHS HAS
BEEN MORE THAN A FULL TIME JOB.
THERE ARE A LOT OF POTENTIALLY
GREAT PROGRAMS INCLUDING
EXPANDED LEARNING ON THE DOCKET
THAT WILL BENEFIT STUDENTS IN
THE YEARS TO COME. BUT THERE ARE
ALSO A LOT OF THINGS IN MOTION
CONCURRENTLY AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE KEEPS THOSE CURRENT
CONDITIONS AT SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
MIND DURING THE DELIBERATIONS ON
THE EXPANDED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH
IN OAKLAND ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT YOLO COUNTY FELL
FLAT AND CURRENT TREASURER TO
THE THOUGHT THAT BOTH THE ASIAN
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL AND SUPPORT
THE INCREASE OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO THAT THEY SPENDING.
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT NO ALLEY A THRIFTY DEAR
SESSIONAL EDUCATION DOLLARS NEXT
YEAR AT THIS YEAR'S ONE TIME
PUBLIC RELATED BY ARE REMOVED WE
ARE ALSO APPRECIATED THE
ANALYSIS AND THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE L. A. L. IN
REGARD TO MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
WHICH ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO
IMPACT TO OUR REGIONAL LIFE
MENTAL HEALTH COURT. AGREED AND
SO MANY OF OU FELLOW BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED ATTENTION. COMPARED WITH THE SEVERITY.
THANK YOU FOR. MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE'S
YEAH- GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ITEM MINOR ON THE PARENTS AND
THE COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVE ENNA FOUNDER OF A
CHARITABLE ORGANIZATION
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS MY- GREAT
APPRECIATION TO THE FIRST
PRESENTER FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
GROUP THAT- TESTBED THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS BUT OUR-
GENERAL EDUCATION STUDENTS FIRST
- AND ALSO I. I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS THAT I'M IN LINE WITH
OTHER COMMENTS RELATED TO THAT
ALI H. RECEIVING INCREASED HER
EIGHTY AMOUNT AS WELL AS THE
CONCERN EXPRESSED ABOUT THE
REDIRECTION OF EDUCATIONALLY.
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING FROM SOUTHWEST VALLEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MARK SAYS THERE AGO
SERVICIOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATION
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN
AS HE- REPRESENTING MUSIC
TEACHERS IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CMEA IS APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY NINE
MILLION PROPOSED IN THE EXPANDED
A LOT PROGRAMS TARGETED FOR
MUSIC AND OTHER ARTS EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. STUDIES SHOW THAT
THERE ARE COGNITIVE AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH MUSIC AND THE ARTS CMEA IS
ALSO APPRECIATIVE THAT THIS
PROPOSED IS- TO EXPAND
INCORPORATE OR SUPPLEMENT
FUNDING FOR MUSIC AND ARTS
PROGRAMS FOR THEM BUT YOU LEFT
PROGRAM HOWEVER CMEA IS SEEKING
ASSURANCES THAT THIS PROPOSED
FUNDING ALSO BE TREATED AS A
SUPPLEMENT TO CURRENT FUNDING
USED BY ELEAZAR. PORT IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION OF MUSIC
AND OTHER ARTS EDUCATION
PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY OUR
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXTCALLER
. NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JAN DIETRICH ON
BEHALF OF THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND I
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE IT'S A COALITION OF
EXPANDED LEARNING PROVIDERS AND
CHILD ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY ON THE
EXPANDED LEARNING. ISSUE WE'VE
BEEN TALKING WITH EVERY AS AND
THEIR COMMUNITY PARTNERS ACROSS
THE STATE AND WE TO HEAR THAT
STAFFING REMAINS THE NUMBER ONE
CHALLENGE IN IMPLEMENTING YELLOW
. IN ORDER FOR ELO KEY TO WORK
AND WE NEED TO ACT GLOBAL LIVING
WAGES FOR THAT HORRIFIC
WORKFORCE. AND WANT TO BE SURE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS CAN RECRUIT
AND RETAIN THE STAFF TO BUILD
UPON THE ACES AND TWENTY FIRST
PROGRAMS AS MENTIONED TODAY. SO
THAT THEY CAN HELP PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT BRITISH. GALA FOR ELO
P. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS
TO ADEQUATELY FIND ALL THESE
PROGRAMS NOT JUST FOR ELEMENTARY
STUDENTS- ALSO LOOK FOR GET
BETTER ALIGNMENT COLLECTING DATA
FROM THESE PROGRAMS TO ENSURE.
THE LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION'S
GOAL OF PROVIDING UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO AFTERSCHOOL AND SUMMER
LEARNING PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE
YOUR CONVERSATION TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIC
PRIMACK WITH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER WANT TO URGE
YOU TO EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE NON CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOLS. CURRENTLY THE
LAWS EXCLUDE THEM FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THIS PROGRAM
WELL NOTE THAT MANY OF THE
FAMILIES SERVED BY THE SCHOOL
CRAP WORK AND LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT DON'T ALIGN WITH THE- EIGHT
TO FIVE PARADIGM IF YOU WILL
THEN NEED SOME OPTIONS NOW ALSO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
TO. MR BLATTNER AND MISTER FUNK
REGARDING THE NEED FOR. A NUMBER
OF PRACTICAL CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS- I'M GOING
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR MODERATOR I KNOW
YOU SAID ORIGINALLY THERE WERE
ELEVEN ON THE LINE HOW MANY DO
WE HAVE WE JUST COMPLETED.
ELEVEN HOW MANY DO WE HAVE IN
THE QUEUE NOW. WE HAVE TO AT
THIS TIME THEN. WELL DO THEM
BOTH- MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS VERONICA CUTS AND I
REPRESENT FIFTEEN SMALL ALLEY
ASIAN PAYMENT COUNTY I'M CALLING
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
FUNDING INCREASE FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES I LIE I ALIGN
MYSELF WITH MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE INSURING THAT NO
ALLEY A- REFRESH EDUCATION
DOLLAR FOR PR. I WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REDIRECTION
OF EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUNDING FROM
SOUTH ALLEY EIGHT THE PROPOSAL
WOULD DISRUPT THESE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SERVICES INCREASED
COSTS AND SUGAR LAYOFF NOTICES
NEXT MONTH I FUNDING ELIMINATED
FOR ABOUT THE PROVIDING REGIONAL
SERVICE AS IT WILL BE ON AT
FAULT I'M SERVICE. YOU CAN LARA
AT A LEVEL OF SERVICE WOULD
BECOME ON THE U. THAT KIND OF
PUT INTO PERSPECTIVE MY LARGEST
ALLEY A WIN NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO
HIRE A PART TIME CLINICIAN AND
MIKE MONTGOMERY I WOULD NOT EVEN
BE ABLE TO BUY MORE. THAN A FEW
FASHION. MONEY EACH OTHER WITH A
THREE NOT. IT WOULD BE KIND OF.
AND NOT NOT ONLY A THAT. ONLY A
TO A ON INTRICATE MODEL SERVICE
. IT WOULD ALSO EXAMINE AFTER
THEY ARE PRESENT BACK I SHORTAGE
CRISIS ADDITIONALLY BETTER
LAYERED I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERN AND OF THE AROUND
SPECIAL. REGULATION CONTINUING
TO FIND PROMOTE THE PEOPLE AND
REFEREES OF THE DURING THE TIME
I THINK THERE ARE ENOUGH
SOLUTIONS ON GO CREDIT ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD MUCH MORE CONVERTS
. THANK YOU FOR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
IF YOU WISH TO PROVIDE SEPARATE
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK
THOSE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS ARE
WE WOULD BE. HAPPY TO RECEIVE A
MODERATOR- WHAT I THINK MIGHT BE
THE LAST CALLER. YES IT'S- THE
FINAL COMMENT IN Q. COMES FROM
MINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING AFTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
IS GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE'RE STILL COMPILING A
FORMAL RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET BUT
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
ALLOCATIONS SUCH OFFICIALLY WAS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING. SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AND
CLARITY ON DOWN THE LINE WOULD
INCLUDE- THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
NUMBER OF. BOB PRESCHOOL CLASS
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION PUPILS
WERE WORRIED THAT THAT MIGHT BE
TOO LOW. THE WIDE THE PERCENTAGE
OF STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES ARE
APPROXIMATELY 12213% SO. WOULD
THINKING THAT THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PEOPLE'S AT LEAST MATCH THAT.
CENTER WE ALSO HAVE- QUESTIONS I
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS ABOUT THE
ALTERNATIVES AT THE TOP OF MY
CRITERIA FOR GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. CERTAINLY WE THINK
THAT MAKING DIPLOMAS MORE
ACCEPTABLE TO MORE STUDENTS WHO
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EARN THEM A
GOOD THING- BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT SCHOOL ISSUE DIPLOMAS
TO STUDENTS WITH IEPS- YOU KNOW
WON'T. TAKE SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
OUT OF TRANSITION PROGRAM
INCLUDE NEEDED. AND SO- BASED ON
THE ADDITION TO. THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADDENDUM HOWEVER
SEEKING SOME ADDITIONAL CLARITY
THAT'S NOT WHAT OUTCOMES THAT
WOULD BE MEASURED AS PART OF IT-
INCLUSION WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT AS WELL AS OTHER
OUTCOMES THAT WE LOOK FOR TO.
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION FOR
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENDDA
MODERATOR. OF LET ME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR VERY EFFICIENT-
ORGANIZATION. OF THESE CALLERS.
X. FOR BRITISH WITH THE TODAY.
AND AS WE COME TO THE END LET ME
ASK SENATOR CHAU BLOG CLOSER
COMMENTS. C. NONE THEN LET ME
THANK EVERYONE WHO PUT. IN THE
HE TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. ARE YOU COULD-SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS OR IF YOU HAD TO CUT
OFF YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE OF
TIME LIMITS HELLO YOU COULD FIX
A SUBMIT COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AS WELL. TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE-
WE VALUE THOSE COMMENTS THEY'RE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US. SO THANKS
TO EVERYONE FOR THEIR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING ARE WE WILL MEET
TOMORROW MORNING AT NINE O'CLOCK
IN THIS VERY ROOM T CONSIDER
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET. OF THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
STANDS ADJOURNED. I DON'T WANT.